THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US FOR THIS MEETING
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THE SENATE WELCOMES
THE PUBLIC IN PERSON AND WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
IN THE Þ STREET BUILDING. I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
BE PRESENT IN ROOM 2200 SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND
BEGIN OUR HEARING, FIRST, I HAVE
A VERY SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT. IT
IS THE BIRTHDAY OF OUR BELOVED
CONSULTANT, JONATHAN PETERSON.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY. JONATHAN SO
LET'S DO GIVE HIM A BIG BIRTHDAY
PRESENT AND GET OUT OF HERE IN
HALF AN HOUR. NO, I'M JUST
KIDDING. JUST KIDDING, JUST
KIDDING. WE'RE WE HAD TEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA, NONE OF WHICH
ARE. NONE OF WHICH ARE IN
CONSENT, BUT WE DO HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING NOTES. FILE NUMBER
6AB 2433 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S HEARING FILE NUMBER TEN
A B 2922 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GARCIA HAS ALSO BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S HEARING. THAT LEAVES US
WITH EIGHT BILLS FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERNER
HAS REQUESTED TO GO FIRST, AND I
HAVE GRANTED HER REQUEST. WE DO,
WE HAVE. WE CAN START. OKAY
WE'LL START AS A SUB
SUBCOMMITTEE. SINCE WE HAVE, WE
DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM, SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERNER, PLEASE
COME ON UP. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL. AB 2715 WOULD SIMPLY
ADD THREATS TO CYBER SECURITY TO
THE LIST OF CLOSED SESSION
EXEMPTIONS IN THE BROWN ACT.
CURRENTLY, LOCAL AGENCIES CAN
ALREADY HOLD A CLOSED, CLOSED
SESSION TO DISCUSS THREATS TO
THE SECURITY OF PUBLIC
BUILDINGS. THE SECURITY OF
ESSENTIAL PUBLIC SERVICES, OR
THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT OF ACCESS TO
PUBLIC SERVICES OR PUBLIC
FACILITIES. HOWEVER, CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT EXPLICITLY LIST THREATS
TO CYBER SECURITY AS A REASON TO
MEET IN CLOSED SESSION. AS A
RESULT, LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
POTENTIALLY FORCED TO DISCUSS
CYBER SECURITY THREATS AND
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS IN OPEN
SESSION. THIS COULD LEAVE LOCAL
AGENCIES OPEN TO MORE CYBER
SECURITY ATTACKS. AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES,
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS ARE ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY. WE ARE ALREADY
ALREADY ADDRESSED IN EXISTING
LAW. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AT AN APPROPRIATE TIME
AND WITH ME, I HAVE DANE
HUTCHINGS, REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF CARLSBAD. GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, DANE
HUTCHINGS, REPRESENTING THE CITY
OF CARLSBAD, I WANT TO THANK,
THE AUTHOR FOR CARRYING THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF THE CITY, THE
CITY ATTORNEY IS TASKED WITH
PROVIDING LEGAL COUNSEL AND
SERVICES TO THE CITY COUNCIL,
CITY DEPARTMENTS AND CITY
BOARDS, BUT JUST AS IMPORTANTLY,
PROTECTING PUBLIC INFORMATION.
THE BROWN ACT WAS ENACTED IN
1953, AND ALTHOUGH IT HAS BEEN
AMENDED OVER THE YEARS, IT DOES
NOT ACKNOWLEDGE THE LEVEL TO
WHICH TECHNOLOGY HAS ADVANCED.
MORE SPECIFICALLY, CYBERSECURITY
THREATS FACING PUBLIC AGENCIES.
WHILE THE BROWN ACT DOES ALLOW
FOR DISCUSSION TO OCCUR IN
CLOSED SESSION REGARDING
SPECIFIC SECURITY THREATS, IT IS
SILENT ON THE GENERAL TOPIC OF
CYBERSECURITY 2715. WOULD ALLOW
FOR CLOSED SESSION BRIEFINGS
ABOUT GENERAL CYBERSECURITY
THREATS, THUS MAKING THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY MORE INFORMED
ABOUT THE NATURE OF THE THREATS
AND THE EXTENT OF THE AGENCY'S
VULNERABILITIES. WITH THE
APPROPRIATE GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY TO THE PUBLIC. AS
ESTABLISHED IN EXISTING LAW, FOR
EXAMPLE, IF REDUCING A
VULNERABILITY TO CYBER ATTACKS
WOULD REQUIRE A FINANCIAL
INVESTMENT SUCH AS A PROCUREMENT
OR A LARGE SOFTWARE CONTRACT,
THAT INVESTMENT WOULD BE
DETERMINED IN OPEN SESSION. BUT
THE CLOSED SESSION WOULD ALLOW
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY TO LEARN, A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
VULNERABILITY, WHY THE
INVESTMENT IS NEEDED WITHOUT
DISCLOSING THE SPECIFIC
VULNERABILITY TO CYBER TO CYBER
CRIMINALS, THE BROWN ACT
CURRENTLY REQUIRES CLOSED
SESSION AGENDAS TO STATE THE
STATIONARY OR STATUTORY
AUTHORIZATION FOR CLOSED
SESSION. AND IN THAT CASE, IF
THE SECURITY THREATS TO IDENTIFY
WITH WHOM THE LEGISLATIVE BODY
IS MEETING WITH 2715 IS A MODEST
AMENDMENT TO CLOSED SESSION
PROVISIONS IN THE BROWN ACT THAT
WILL ALLOW LOCAL AGENCIES TO
PROTECT SENSITIVE INFORMATION
THAT COULD PUT AT GREATER RISK
OF CYBER ATTACKS. I THANK YOU
ONCE AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERING OF CARLSBAD'S
REQUEST AND URGE YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB 2715. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE
THEM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
MORE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS. DOROTHY
JOHNSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. PLEASED TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SARAH
DUQUETTE, ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. PLEASED TO SUPPORT,
GENE HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. ALYSSA. HI. I GOT A
LIST. I'M GOING TO READ IT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY CLERKS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICTS,
THE CITY OF REDWOOD CITY, CITY
OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA, CITY OF
RANCHO PALOS VERDES, AND CITY OF
EASTVALE, ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
JOHNNY PINA. WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. I'M ERIC LEHR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION. COUNTIES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
ARAMBULA KERN ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA, IT AND EDUCATION IN
SMALL SCHOOL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY MORE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT, SEEING NONE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE COME UP. WE'LL GIVE YOU
TWO MINUTES. SURE. I'LL BE
BRIEF. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M GINNY LARUE WITH
THE FIRST AMENDMENT COALITION, A
NONPROFIT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE STAFF AND PROPONENTS FOR
TALKING WITH US ABOUT THIS BILL.
OUR POSITION RIGHT NOW IS
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED, AND WE
ONLY SEEK SOME VERY MINOR
CLARIFICATIONS TO THE BILL. AND
BECAUSE THEY'VE ALREADY WORKED
TO DO WHAT WE THINK REALLY,
GIVES SOME NARROW AND SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE THAT HAS THE RIGHT
BALANCE FOR PRIVACY AND PUBLIC
ACCESS AND ACCOUNTABILITY. WE
HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION, TO GET SOME MINOR
CLARIFICATIONS THAT WE THINK ARE
IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC WHEN
THEY SEE THESE AGENDAS AND THESE
CLOSED SESSIONS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY MORE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? OKAY
SEEING NONE, WE'LL COME BACK
HERE TO THE COMMITTEE. SENATOR
WAHAB AND THEN SENATOR SUGIARTO.
THANK YOU, I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, I WORKED IN TECHNOLOGY
AS WELL AS BEING A LOCAL MEMBER
OF A CITY COUNCIL, AND ONE. AND
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THIS
BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE BEING
TARGETED VERY SPECIFICALLY ONLY
BY THOSE THAT ARE EITHER TRYING
TO MAKE A PROFIT OFF OF IT OR
MAKE A SHOW OF IT, IN THE BAY
AREA, WHICH, YOU KNOW, I
REPRESENT THE SILICON VALLEY, A
NUMBER OF SMALLER CITIES HAVE
BEEN VERY MUCH TARGETED, AS WELL
AS COLLEGES AND WHETHER THEIR
ENTIRE INFRASTRUCTURE IS TAKEN
OVER OR SHUT DOWN OR ANYTHING.
AND THE NOMINAL REQUEST THAT
THESE HACKERS ARE KIND OF
REQUESTING IS ANYWHERE FROM
$50,000 TO ROUGHLY $1 MILLION OR
SO, IT'S VERY HARD TO TRACE AND
I WILL SAY JUST EVEN COMPETING
FOR THE BEST OF, YOU KNOW, IT
AND SECURITY AND SO FORTH IS
VERY DIFFICULT ON SCHOOL BUDGETS
AS WELL AS CITY COUNCILS AND SO
FORTH, ESPECIALLY SMALLER
CITIES, ALSO SOME OF THE LARGER
TECH COMPANIES DON'T HAVE A
SPECIAL LIAISON TO THESE
PARTICULAR CITIES, RIGHT? THEY
MAY HAVE IT FOR A LARGE COUNTY
LIKE SANTA CLARA. COUNTY I
REPRESENT, BUT THEY DON'T EVEN
HAVE SPECIAL LIAISONS TO A CITY
THE SIZE OF OAKLAND. FOR EXAMPLE
. RIGHT. THIS IS INCREDIBLY
PROBLEMATIC, I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
CYBER SECURITY SIGNIFICANTLY AND
THE NEEDS FOR IT. I WILL ALSO
SAY THAT THE REASON WHY THESE
CONVERSATIONS NEED TO BE TAKEN
PLACE IN CLOSED SESSION IS
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT YOU
DON'T WANT TO SHARE YOUR
VULNERABILITIES, YOU KNOW, TO
THE LARGER PUBLIC AND TO PEOPLE
WHO, YOU KNOW, WOULD LIKE TO SEE
SOME DAMAGE DONE, MORE
SPECIFICALLY, WE'VE HAD THIS
INSTANCE IN MY COUNCIL IN
PARTICULAR, WHERE WE TALKED
ABOUT IT ON THE OPEN DÍAS AND,
YOU KNOW, THEY HAD TO TAKE AWAY
MY COMMENTARY VERBALLY, FROM THE
VIDEOS. AND THAT IS, AGAIN, TO
PROTECT THE CITY AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE, THAT CITY, AS WELL AS
A NUMBER OF OTHER CITIES, HAS
BEEN HACKED. AND SO I THINK THAT
THIS IS A GOOD PREVENTATIVE
MEASURE. IT ALLOWS FOR
SUBSTANTIVE CONVERSATION ABOUT
VULNERABILITIES, ABOUT FAULTY
AREAS, ABOUT NEEDS OF
IMPROVEMENT, AND SO MUCH MORE.
SO I FULLY SUPPORT THIS. I
APPRECIATE THE WORK. I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
ATTENTION. I WILL MOVE THE BILL
AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SO THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR BILL. IT'S ACTUALLY
A REALLY GOOD BILL ACTUALLY.
IT'S KEEPING ACTUALLY, I GUESS
THAT WAS WRONG FOR ME TO SAY
ACTUALLY, YOU HAVE A LOT OF GOOD
BILLS. HOW'S THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
RALPH M BROWN ACT IS AN
IMPORTANT ACT FOR GOVERNMENT
TRANSPARENCY AND MAKING SURE
THAT THE PUBLIC KNOWS WHAT'S
GOING ON. BUT AS TECHNOLOGY
MOVES FORWARD, THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE ADDED IN
AND PROTECTED BY THAT. AND THIS
IS ONE OF THEM, JUST LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE SAID, YOU DON'T NEED
EVERYBODY TO KNOW WHAT YOUR
VULNERABILITIES ARE. SO THAT
THEY CAN RUN OUT AND IMMEDIATELY
ATTACK YOUR, YOUR, YOUR AGENCY
AND SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT AS
WELL. WHEN WE GET ENOUGH, THE
ONLY REASON I DECIDED TO ADD ON
IN TALKING IS BECAUSE I DON'T
SEE ANOTHER AUTHOR HERE. OH YES
WE DO, WE DO. OKAY, GOOD. SO
NOW, NOW I'LL BE QUIET AND. AND
JUST SAY YOU CAN, WE'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL WHEN IT
COMES UP. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
GREAT. OKAY CLOSING REMARKS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE.
AND THANK YOU TO BOTH OF THE
MEMBERS WHO SPOKE IN FAVOR. IT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
THAT COUNCIL MEMBERS AND SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS ARE ABLE TO BE
INFORMED ABOUT WHAT THE
VULNERABILITIES ARE AND IN A
DEEP WAY. AND WE'VE DONE WE'VE
TAKEN MANY AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT THERE'S THE NECESSARY
TRANSPARENCY THAT WE WANT WITH
OUR PUBLIC AGENCIES. SO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, WE AGAIN, WHEN
WE GET OUR QUORUM, WE'LL, TAKE
THE VOTES. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
GOING BACK TO THE ACTUAL ORDER
HERE, GO BACK, NUMBER ONE, AB
817, ASSEMBLY MEMBER PACHECO.
WELCOME.
GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK
YOU, GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, TODAY I PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 817. I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. AND TODAY, I WILL BE
ACCEPTING MOST OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB 817 IS A SIMPLE
BILL THAT DOES JUST ONE MAIN
THING. AND I KNOW WE ALL SAY
IT'S A SIMPLE BILL, BUT IT
REDUCES BARRIERS TO ENTRY FOR
CIVIC PARTICIPATION. OPENING THE
PIPELINE TO PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT
AND FUTURE ELECTED OFFICE TO
INCLUDE MORE DIVERSE AND
INCLUSIVE VARIETY OF
CALIFORNIANS. AB 817 ACHIEVES
THIS BY ALLOWING NON-DECISION
MAKING ADVISORY ONLY BODIES AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY WITHOUT POSTING THEIR
LOCATION FOR PUBLIC ACCESS,
WHILE MAINTAINING PUBLIC ACCESS
AND TRANSPARENCY IN GOVERNANCE
THROUGH REQUIRING THE USE OF TWO
WAY AUDIO VISUAL TECHNOLOGY FOR
ALL MEETINGS. UTILIZING THIS
AUTHORITY, THE GOAL IS TO BRING
PARITY AMONG THE NEW STATE
STANDARDS FOR STATE ADVISORY
BODIES CREATED IN SB 544 AND
LOCAL NON DECISION MAKING
ADVISORY BODIES WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 817 IS
JANEY WHITEFORD, PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA IHSS CONSUMER
ALLIANCE AND IS A MEMBER OF THE
SANTA CLARA IHSS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. AND ALSO WE HAVE
ETHAN RARICK, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION,
AND I WILL PASS IT OVER TO MY
WITNESSES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GO AHEAD AND, WE'LL GIVE YOU TWO
MINUTES. DO YOU HAVE A SECOND
WITNESS AS WELL? YES. OKAY. SO
TWO MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WELCOME. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR DURAZO AND
MEMBERS, THE COALITION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AB 817 AS IT PROVIDES
EQUITY, INCLUSION THAT IS
CURRENTLY MISSING IN TWO WAY
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT PROCESS FOR
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD ON CRITICAL ISSUES
THAT IMPACT THEIR QUALITY OF
LIFE. AS CALIFORNIA'S MASTER
PLAN ON AGING ARTICULATES, WE
NEED TO CREATE COMMUNITIES WHERE
PEOPLE OF ALL AGES AND ABILITIES
ARE ENGAGED VALUES AND AFFORDED
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
THRIVE. AB 817 ALIGNS WITH THIS
IMPORTANT POLICY OBJECTIVE, AS
WELL AS SUPPORTS THE AMERICANS
WITH DISABILITIES ACT. CURRENT
LAW PUTS MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY
AT RISK, PROVIDING ONLY TWO
OPTIONS EITHER WE MUST
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON OR WE CAN
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY AND ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS TO OUR HOMES,
REGARDLESS OF HOW COMPROMISING
AND POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS THIS
COULD BE. THIS DOES NOT MEET THE
DESIRED THRESHOLD OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S DESIRED GOALS FOR
EQUAL ACCESS AND EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. IN CIVIC
LEADERSHIP. CALIFORNIA IS A HUGE
STATE, AND MOST COUNTIES HAVE A
LARGE GEOGRAPHIC AREA, AND
MEMBERS FIND IT VERY DIFFICULT
IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE, TO ATTEND
MEETINGS AND THESE MEETINGS DO
NOT MEET BECAUSE A QUORUM NEEDS,
CANNOT BE MET DUE TO THE
IN-PERSON MEETING REQUIREMENT.
IF YOU CANNOT CONDUCT BUSINESS
DUE TO A LACK OF QUORUM, THE
ALTERNATIVE IS THAT WE SIMPLY DO
NOT MEET AND COUNTY DECISION
MAKERS ARE LEFT WITHOUT LOCAL
INPUT. WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO ALLOW ALLOW MORE VOICES TO BE
HEARD AND FOR AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL TO
PARTICIPATE IN ADVISING OUR
COUNTY OFFICIALS IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY ON MY IHSS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE, ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
RESIGNED BECAUSE TAKING
PARATRANSIT THAT WOULD TAKE HER
SIX HOURS OF TIME, NOT FEASIBLE
IN RURAL COUNTIES AND VERY LARGE
AREAS, AREAS SUCH AS SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY. IT CAN TAKE A
HALF DAY TO GET TO A MEETING
SITE. IT IS THE RARE CITIZEN WHO
WILL DO THIS IS AND IS AN
IMPOSSIBLE BAR TO SET FOR THE
PUBLIC TO HAVE A VOICE. FOR
THESE REASONS AND MANY MORE
ANECDOTE'S WE COULD SHARE, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
SUPPORT AB 817. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I WILL BE BRIEF. MY
NAME IS ETHAN RARICK. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION. THE
COMMISSION IS AN INDEPENDENT,
BIPARTISAN AGENCY CHARGED WITH
MAKING RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
REFORM OF STATE GOVERNMENT. WE
CAME TO THIS ISSUE BECAUSE WE
MET SUCCESSFULLY USING REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY DURING THE PANDEMIC.
SUBSEQUENTLY, WE SURVEYED OTHER
AGENCIES GOVERNED BY THE
BAGLEY-KEENE ACT ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCES MEETING USING REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY. 95% SAID THEY
EXPERIENCED MORE PUBLIC
ATTENDANCE, MORE THAN 90% SAID
THEY HAD SAVED MONEY DUE TO
REDUCED TRAVEL AND TRAVEL AND
FACILITY RENTAL COSTS. ABOUT
HALF SAID THEY HAD EXPERIENCED
GREATER PARTICIPATION BY MEMBERS
OF THE BODY, AND NONE REPORTED
LESS PARTICIPATION. ACCORDINGLY,
LAST YEAR WE SUPPORTED SB 544,
WHICH MADE ANALOGOUS CHANGES TO
THIS BILL. THAT BILL AFFECTED
THE BAGLEY-KEENE ACT. AS YOU
KNOW, AND WE WERE HAPPY TO SEE
THAT BILL ENACTED AND WE HAVE
RECOMMENDED AND SUPPORT SIMILAR
USE FOR THE FOR THE BROWN ACT.
WE BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE DIVERSITY AND
REPRESENTATION ON PUBLIC BODIES
AROUND THE STATE. IT WILL MAKE
GOVERNMENT LOOK MORE LIKE
CALIFORNIA AT LARGE. AND WE
THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING.
THEREFORE, RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, ANY MORE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF YOU
WOULD COME UP AND GIVE YOUR
NAME, ORGANIZATION AND WHERE YOU
STAND ON THE BILL? KIM
ROTHSCHILD, CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES FOR IN-HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS, GREGORY
KRAMER, ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA, AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR DAN
OCKENFELS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS, MARTIN VENDIOLA, ON
BEHALF OF THE METROPOLITAN
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION, THE ASSOCIATION OF
BAY AREA GOVERNMENTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. KATE LATOUCHE, CHAIR OF
THE YOLO COUNTY IN-HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND CO-FOUNDER OF THE
NONPARTISAN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
GROUP DEMOCRACY WINTERS AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. JASON EICHER, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
CHOICE ASSOCIATION. BOTH ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS,
MATTHEW SEIBERLING, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTION OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. CINDY PEREZ, ON
BEHALF OF YOLO COUNTY AND
SUPPORT. MONNING JEFF NEAL,
REPRESENTING SAN DIEGO COUNTY,
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY, IMPERIAL
COUNTY, AND LAKE COUNTY ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, GOOD
MORNING, JEAN HURST HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA, ALONG WITH THE
COUNTY BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS OF
THE COUNTIES OF RIVERSIDE,
VENTURA, SANTA BARBARA AND SANTA
CRUZ IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, JOHNNY PINA. WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES,
PROUD CO-SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. AND JIM VON Dð
WITH THE YOLO COUNTY CLIMATE
ACTION COMMISSION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. MOIRA
TAUB HERE ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO AND ORANGE
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
AND SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
SYLVIA SOLIS SHA HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF WEST HOLLYWOOD,
SANTA MONICA AND GOLETA, AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF MONTEREY,
SALINAS TRANSIT. THANK YOU,
SARAH DUQUETTE, ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA, A PROUD CO-SPONSOR
FOR GOOD MORNING, DEVON ANDERSON
ON BEHALF OF SAN MATEO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. ALYSSA SALEHI, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RECREATION AND
PARK DISTRICTS, A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR IN SUPPORT AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE BURBANK,
GLENDALE, PASADENA AIRPORT
AUTHORITY, THE CITY CLERKS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, CITY
OF BELMONT, CITY OF CARLSBAD,
CITY OF FOSTER, CITY CITY OF
MOUNTAIN VIEW, CITY OF RANCHO
CUCAMONGA, CITY OF SANTA ROSA.
CITY OF REDWOOD CITY, AND TOWN
OF HILLSBORO. ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. MARK FENSTERMAKER ON
BEHALF OF PENINSULA CLEAN ENERGY
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. ANDREW ANTHONY, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS, THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY, THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES, THE SAN MATEO CITY
COUNTY ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS, CALTRAIN AND THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT, ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. DYLAN. ELLIE
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTIES OF
NAPA, MENDOCINO, SAN JOAQUIN,
SOLANO, AND SONOMA ALL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, DOROTHY JOHNSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. PLEASED TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI. MY NAME
IS ELLEN BRITTINGHAM. I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY
POWER AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, KIARA
ROSS, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN MARCOS AND THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL OF MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS, ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, CASSANDRA MÀ,
ON BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF APPLE
VALLEY AND THE CITY OF DOWNEY
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MICHAEL
PIMENTEL HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
AND OUR MORE THAN 100 PUBLIC
AGENCY MEMBERS IN SUPPORT, ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, KATHY MOSSBERG, ON BEHALF
OF THE AREA AGENCIES ON AGING
AND STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. MARCHESE, ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS NICK ROMO
WITH CRUZ STRATEGIES ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY REGIONAL
AIRPORT AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. I'M
ERIC LARA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL 58
COUNTIES, PROUD CO-SPONSOR.
THANK YOU, STEVE WALLACH, ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION, THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT, THE NAPA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY, AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
COORDINATED TRANSPORTATION
COLLECT AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, KEISHA HUNT WITH
NORSEMAN ON BEHALF OF COUNTY
MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MARCUS DETWILER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS DAN SHAW ON BEHALF OF
AVA COMMUNITY ENERGY, FORMERLY
EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
. MY NAME IS RICHARD WHITE. I
CHAIR THE ADVISORY COUNCIL TO
THE NAPA SOLANO AREA AGENCY ON
AGING WITH OVER 140,000 OLDER
ADULTS. YOU WE MET YESTERDAY SO
WE WERE UNABLE TO SUBMIT A
POSITION LETTER ON TIME. BUT WE
DID MEET, MEET AND WE ISSUED A
STATEMENT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB 817. SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
VOTE AYE ON THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BRENDAN TUIG, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION,
AND THAT'S THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS FROM ALL 35
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? OKAY. SEEING NONE,
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE
COME UP AND YOU'LL HAVE TWO
MINUTES IF YOU WISH. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, BRITTANY BARSOTTI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS, AND REGRETFULLY, IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL, WE'VE
WORKED VERY HARD OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS TO ATTEMPT TO
MODERNIZE THE BROWN ACT AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY,
WE WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH THIS
COMMITTEE ON AB 2449 AND HAVE
ENCOURAGED THE AUTHOR AND OTHERS
WHO ARE SEEKING MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO WORK WITHIN THAT STRUCTURE.
IF THERE ARE MORE CATEGORIES OF
FOLKS OR SETS OF CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT NEED TO BE ADDED SO THEY
HAVE ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
UNDER JUST CAUSE, WE ARE MORE
THAN OPEN TO THAT CONVERSATION.
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE HASN'T BEEN
ANY MOVEMENT TOWARDS THAT, WE
HAVE ALSO OFFERED TO ALLOW SOME,
SOMEONE WITH A DISABILITY TO
COUNT TOWARDS THE IN-PERSON
QUORUM LIKE WE DID WITH SB 544.
OR, YOU KNOW, IF THERE'S
ADDITIONAL LIKE EXCESSIVE TRAVEL
OR THINGS OF THAT OR SOMEONE'S
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED, RIGHT? THOSE
ARE DISCUSSIONS THAT HAVE COME
UP OVER THE LAST YEARS. AND IF
THE AUTHOR HAD ACCEPTED IN
PERSON QUORUM REQUIREMENT WITH
CERTAIN CAVEATS, THEN WE WOULD
LIKELY NOT STILL BE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. UNFORTUNATELY, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT THAT
IS NOT THE CASE. AND IT IS
UNFORTUNATE. ALSO, I'LL NOTE
THAT ESSENTIALLY ALL OF THE
BROWN ACT BILLS COME UP FOR
RENEWAL IN JANUARY 1ST OF 2026.
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO
BE HAVING THIS DETAILED
CONVERSATION AGAIN NEXT YEAR, WE
ARE MORE THAN WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE GOALS OF
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION ARE
REACHED, SO WITH THAT,
UNFORTUNATELY, RESPECTFULLY MAIN
OPPOSED AND I'LL BE AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS WELL.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING AGAIN,
MADAM CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AGAIN, I'M JENNY
LAREAU WITH THE FIRST AMENDMENT
COALITION, A NONPROFIT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S BEEN WORKING
FOR ABOUT 30 YEARS ON OPEN
GOVERNMENT AND FREE PRESS
ISSUES, WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO WE BELIEVE
THAT THE BROADEST RANGE OF
ENGAGED AND INFORMED COMMUNITY
IS THE PUBLIC, IS ESSENTIAL TO
THE HEALTH OF OUR DEMOCRACY. SO
WE'RE OPPOSED TO AB 817 BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE IT WILL DECREASE
GOVERNMENT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND STIFLE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. A FEW EXAMPLES. SO
THESE SUBSIDIARY BODIES, THEY
SERVE IN AN ADVISORY CAPACITY
UNDER THIS NEW DEFINITION THAT
WOULD BE WRITTEN INTO THE BROWN
ACT FOR THE FIRST TIME. BUT WE
BELIEVE THEY ARE NÓ DESERVING OF
THE SAME LEVEL OF PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT, PARTICIPATION AND
SCRUTINY THAT ANY OTHER BROWN
ACT BODY. THAT WAS THE PURPOSE
OF THE BROWN ACT. SO, FOR
INSTANCE, IN IN VALLEJO, YEARS
OF ORGANIZING AND ACTIVISM,
INCLUDING BY FAMILIES OF THOSE
KILLED BY POLICE, HAS LED TO THE
FORMATION OF A POLICE OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
THIS IS A PLACE WHERE MEMBERS OF
IMPACTED FAMILIES WHO HAVE FACED
POLICE VIOLENCE CAN SHOW UP AND
ASK QUESTIONS, EVEN THOUGH THIS
IS AN ADVISORY BODY, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO THE COMMUNITY.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE, AT A RECENT SAN
DIEGO BUDGET REVIEW COMMITTEE, A
LOCAL ACTIVIST IMPLORED PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM TO STAND UP IF THEY
BELIEVED THAT PROPOSED BUDGET
CUTS TO EQUITY PROGRAMS WERE
WRONG. INSTANTLY, THE COMMITTEE
SAW BEFORE THEM A ROOM FULL OF
CONSTITUENTS THERE IN SOLIDARITY
, SOME WEARING MATCHING SHIRTS,
HOLDING SIGNS. A COMMITTEE
MEMBER WAS EVEN MOVED TO JOIN
THEM IN THE DISPLAY.
TELECONFERENCING SIMPLY WOULDN'T
ALLOW THE COMMUNITY TO SEND THE
SAME KIND OF MESSAGE. THAT'S WHY
WE HAVE JOINED THE NEWS
PUBLISHERS, ACLU AND MANY
OTHERS, AND ASKING THAT THERE
ALWAYS BE AN IN-PERSON QUORUM
AND A SINGULAR PHYSICAL LOCATION
WHERE THE COMMUNITY CAN ORGANIZE
. AND FINALLY, I JUST WANT TO
SHARE NEWSPAPERS AROUND THE
STATE HAVE WEIGHED IN OPPOSING
THIS AND SIMILAR BILLS FOR
SEVERAL YEARS, AND A COUPLE MORE
EDITORIALS CAME OUT THIS WEEK
THAT I THINK REALLY TAP INTO THE
HEART OF THE ISSUE IN THE
MERCURY NEWS THIS WEEK. THE
EDITORIAL BOARD SAID THIS IS
ANOTHER STEP DOWN THE SLIPPERY
SLOPE TOWARD LOCAL GOVERNMENT
SECRECY. IT WENT ON TO SAY STATE
LAWMAKERS SHOULD BE WORKING TO
INCREASE CIVIC ENGAGEMENT FOR
THE PEOPLE TO INCREASE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE POLICY PROCESS,
AND THIS WOULD DO JUST THE
OPPOSITE. AND THE LA TIMES
SIMILAR SENTIMENTS, AND THIS IS
THE POINT. WE'RE YOU COULD WRAP
UP. YES, MA'AM, REMOTE
PARTICIPATION SHOULD NOT BE THE
PUBLIC'S ONLY WAY OF ATTENDING,
NOR SHOULD REMOTE PARTICIPATION
BE THE NORM FOR OFFICIALS. WE
AGREE WITH THAT. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANY MORE, WITNESSES?
ANYBODY ELSE IN OPPOSITION? GOOD
MORNING, SCOTT COBB AND HOWARD
JARVIS. TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION,
ALONG WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION CALIFORNIANS AWARE,
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE, CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION, LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS, CALIFORNIA
MEDIA ALLIANCE, NATIONAL PRESS
PHOTOGRAPHERS ASSOCIATION, AND
NLGJA ASSOCIATION OF LGBTQ
JOURNALISTS, OAKLAND PRIVACY
RADIO TELEVISION DIGITAL NEWS
ASSOCIATION, SAN DIEGO PRO
CHAPTER OF THE SOCIETY OF
PROFESSIONAL JOURNALISTS,
SOCIETY OF PROFESSIONAL
JOURNALISTS, LOS ANGELES SOCIETY
OF PROFESSIONAL JOURNALISTS,
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA STUDENT
PRESS LAW CENTER, ORANGE COUNTY
PRESS CLUB IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION? THÀNH OKAY.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL COME BACK
HERE TO DÍAS. AND, YES, SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU, SO I'M A BIG
ADVOCATE OF OBVIOUSLY USING
TECHNOLOGY. I THINK I WAS ONE OF
THE, THE BIG PEOPLE THAT PUSHED
US TO ALL GET LAPTOPS AND IPADS
AND SO FORTH IN THE SENATE SIDE,
AND WE'RE NOT THERE YET HERE IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE, AND THEN ON A LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE, COVID, OBVIOUSLY
SHOWED AREAS OF, NEED FOR
IMPROVEMENT, EASE OF USE AND SO
FORTH, MY CONCERN WITH A LOT OF
THESE REMOTE TELECONFERENCES, IF
YOU WILL, IS THE ABILITY TO CHAT
PRIVATELY WITH MEMBERS, THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO SHARE,
LIKE, OH, THIS HAPPENED, THAT
HAPPENED. I ALSO THINK IN PERSON
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FEELING IN THE ROOM
. RIGHT. SO, FOR EXAMPLE, ON MY
CITY COUNCIL, WE HAD A LOT OF
ISSUES REGARDING PUBLIC SAFETY
REGARDING, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
ISSUES THAT REALLY AFFECTED
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. AND
SOMETIMES THE FEELING IN THE
ROOM IS ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW, WHAT
CAN STIR A DIFFERENCE OF AN
OPINION, WITH, WITH THIS AND THE
SUBSIDIARY BODIES IN PARTICULAR,
YOU KNOW, I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE, THE PER DIEM. RIGHT, I
THINK THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
ADDRESS THAT. I DON'T BELIEVE IF
WE'VE HAD A RESOLUTION TO THAT,
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO ANSWER
ANYTHING? SURE. SO IT WOULDN'T
APPLY TO CITY COUNCIL, SO IT
WOULDN'T APPLY TO, COUNCILS. IT
WOULDN'T APPLY TO PLANNING
COMMISSIONERS BECAUSE THOSE ARE,
ELECTED BODIES WHO MAKE, THEIR
DECISION MAKING BODIES. THEY'RE
NOT ADVISORY BODIES. SO THIS
BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY TO THOSE
NON DECISION MAKING ADVISORY
COMMUNITY SERVICES, HUMAN
SERVICES. SO IN DOWNEY FOR
INSTANCE WE HAVE PARKS AND REC.
WE HAVE COMMISSIONERS. WE HAVE
PUBLIC WORKS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE WE ALSO HAVE A GREEN
TASK FORCE COMMITTEE, SO IT
WOULD APPLY TO THOSE COMMITTEES
BECAUSE THERE ARE ONLY ADVISORY.
AND AS TO COMPENSATION, MOST OF
THESE DON'T GET COMPENSATED, BUT
SOME OF THESE DO. AND THE
WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE, TO
TESTIFY, WHICH THE MAIN WITNESS,
SHE DROVE THREE HOURS JUST TO
GET HERE, AND SO IT WOULD IT
WOULD HELP THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DISABLED AS WELL. AND AS TO
THE COMPENSATION, MOST OF THEM
DO NOT GET COMPENSATED, BUT SOME
OF THEM DO, DO Tð. AND SO WHAT
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IS WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE, MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE CIVICALLY ENGAGED,
BUT AS WELL, THE MINER
COMPENSATION, COMPENSATION THAT
THEY DO RECEIVE, WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE THAT COMPENSATION. OKAY
AND THEN THE OPPOSITIONS, POINTS
THAT THEY BROUGHT UP, DO YOU
HAVE ANY, REBUTTALS TO THEM? SO
WE ALREADY ALLOW THIS, FOR
DECISION MAKING BODIES AT THE
STATE LEVEL. AND SO THIS BILL
WOULD BE WOULD ONLY APPLY TO
LOCAL LEVELS, OF COURSE THEY
WOULD APPLY STATEWIDE. BUT THERE
IS ALSO A SUNSET. THERE IS A
SUNSET PROVISION WITHIN THIS
BILL, WHICH WOULD BE JULY. I'M
SORRY, JANUARY 1ST, IS IT
JANUARY? YES JULY 1ST, 2026. AND
MAKE SURE JANUARY. BUT IT WOULD
BE 2026. OKAY. AND HAVE YOU
TAKEN THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS? THE I'VE TAKEN SEVEN
OUT OF THE NINE, COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, THE TWO THAT WERE
NOT TAKEN HAD TO DO WITH THE
COMPENSATION THÀNH AND THE
IN-PERSON WORK, QUORUM
REQUIREMENT. AND THE REASON IS
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WHOLE PURPOSE
OF THIS BILL. OKAY YEAH. BUT THE
OTHER AMENDMENTS, IF THIS BILL
MAKES IT THROUGH, WE WILL BE
TAKING THE OTHER SEVEN
AMENDMENTS. OKAY? YEAH. ALL
RIGHT, SO THERE WERE A TOTAL OF
NINE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
PROPOSED AND SO WE'VE AGREED TO
TAKE SEVEN OF THOSE AMENDMENTS.
OKAY. AND THE OTHER TWO THAT YOU
WERE CONCERNED WITH, NOT TAKING
IS WHAT'S THE REASONING AS TO
THE COMPENSATION, LIKE I
EXPLAINED. AND THEN THE
IN-PERSON QUORUM REQUIREMENT,
WHICH IS THE WHOLE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL. BUT AGAIN, THERE IS A
SUNSET ON THIS BILL. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. SO IF IT
DOESN'T WORK, THEN OF COURSE, WE
DON'T EXTEND THE SUNSET. YEAH.
OKAY. ANY COMMENTS? VERY MUCH
COVERED. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WELL,
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO, WE'VE BEEN, FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. I
KNOW IT'S. I KNOW YOUR PURPOSE.
AND ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF ALL
THE PARTICIPATE IN TODAY WAS,
YOU KNOW, IS TO YOU CARE ABOUT
YOUR COMMUNITY AND EVERYONE'S
ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, AS YOU SAID, THE,
THE BILL GIVES SUBSIDIES THREE
BODIES THAT ADVISE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE ABILITY TO
TELECONFERENCE THEIR MEETINGS
WITHOUT PROVIDING THE
TELECONFERENCE LOCATIONS OR
MAKING THEM PUBLICLY ACCESSIBLE,
THESE SUBSIDIARY BODIES ADVISE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ON A BROAD
RANGE OF ISSUES, EVERYTHING FROM
POLICE REFORM TO BUDGETS TO
ELECTIONS. AND YES, THESE BODIES
MAY ONLY MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS,
BUT THEY ARE OFTEN MADE UP OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AS, IN THE
CITY COUNCIL OR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS APPOINT. THEY ARE
OFTEN GIVEN POWER TO DEVELOP
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT INFORM THE
FUTURE ACTIONS THAT OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TAKE. SO IT IS VITAL
THAT THE PUBLIC CAN INFORM THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THESE BODIES
MAKE. I DON'T BELIEVE THAT, YOU
CAN AS EFFECTIVE, DO THAT ON A
COMPUTER SCREEN INSTEAD OF IN
PERSON. BUT DESPITE ALL THE
CONCERNS AND OTHERS THAT, I LAID
OUT, I OFFERED A PATH FOR YOUR
BILL THAT BALANCED THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
MEMBERS OF THESE SUBSIDIES, FREE
BODIES. AND AS YOU SAID, I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU AGREED TO
CERTAIN AMENDMENTS LIKE
NARROWING THE KINDS OF
SUBSIDIARY BODIES THAT COULD USE
A FLEXIBLE CITY. THE REMAINING
TWO POINTS ARE, THAT WE
SUGGESTED THAT MEMBERS THAT
RECEIVE COMPENSATION FOR THEIR
SERVICE, WOULD NOT PARTICIPATE
ON A SUBSIDIARY BODY RECEIVING
THIS ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY.
K¾T, AND SECOND, WE SUGGESTED
REQUIRING THAT A QUORUM OF THE
SUBSIDIARY BODY PARTICIPATE IN
PERSON SO THAT THE PUBLIC CAN
ADDRESS THE BODY DIRECTLY. WE
RECOGNIZE YOUR GOAL, THAT
CERTAIN MEMBERS THAT THOSE WHO
HAVE A DISABILITY MAY HAVE A
DIFFICULTY PARTICIPATING IN
PERSON. SO IN RESPONSE TO THAT
CONCERN, WE OFFERED TO ALLOW,
CERTAIN GROUPS TO COUNT TOWARDS
THAT IN PERSON REQUIREMENT EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY, AND YOU WERE THIS IS,
AS YOU SAID, THE PART THAT YOU
WERE UNWILLING TO ACCEPT. I HOPE
THAT I WAS HOPING THAT WE COULD
FIND A WAY TO RESOLVE THESE
FINAL ISSUES, BUT WE'RE NOT
THERE YET. FOR THAT REASON, I
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY. AND I THINK
PRIMARILY WE HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT IT'S THE BROWN ACT, THE
HEART OF THE BROWN ACT, THAT WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO PROTECT, AND
THAT REQUIRES FACE TO FACE
PARTICIPATION. SO WITH THAT, YOU
CAN HAVE YOUR FINAL CLOSING
REMARKS, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU, SENATORS, AGAIN
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
THIS IMPORTANT BILL THAT WOULD
ALLOW PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE,
WHEN, YOU KNOW, IF THEY'RE
DISABLED OR THEY'RE UNABLE TO
ATTEND THESE IMPORTANT ADVISORY
COMMITTEES, THIS WOULD ALLOW
PARTICIPATION FROM OUR MEMBERS
MORE RESIDENTS. AND, WE'VE TAKEN
A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS. AND
AGAIN, THIS BILL WOULD MERELY,
MIRROR THE SENATE BILL, WHICH
WAS 544, WHICH ALLOWS, STATE
BODIES TO BE ABLE TO MEET REPORT
, MEET REMOTELY. SO IT'S THE
EQUIVALENT TO SB FOUR FOUR. IT
APPLIES TO THE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. AND AGAIN, I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
OKAY. WE'RE NOT TAKING NO STILL
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM OKAY, WE CAN
GO DOWN TO THE NEXT BILL, WHICH
IS COMING UP. THIS BIRD IS HERE.
THE FINAL ITEM, NUMBER TWO, MR.
OKAY. WE'RE MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO, WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZABIR AB 1176.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZABIR. WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING. GO AHEAD, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 1176, WHICH IS
SPONSORED BY CLIMATE PLAN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORTED BY A
WIDE RANGE OF GROUPS INVESTED IN
THE ENVIRONMENT AND A CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE. OUR STATE HAS
ADOPTED AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS
THAT REQUIRE DRASTIC CUTS IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
OUR TRANSPORTATION AND BUILDING
SECTORS. TO MEET THESE GOALS, WE
WILL NEED OVER 1 MILLION
CHARGERS TO SUPPORT THE 8
MILLION ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ANTICIPATED ON THE ROAD BY 2030,
AND EVEN MORE TO MEET THE
STATE'S 2035 ELECTRIC VEHICLE
MANDATE. CALIFORNIA WILL ALSO
NEED TO RETROFIT MUCH OF OUR
EXISTING BUILDINGS TO CUT
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
HOMES AND BUILDINGS, SUCH AS
CONVERTING TO ELECTRIC
APPLIANCES AND EQUIPMENT.
MEETING THESE GOALS REQUIRES
THAT GOVERNMENTS AT ALL LEVELS
PARTNER IN DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING STRATEGIES TO
TRANSITION TO A CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE, ENSURING THAT EV
CHARGING AND BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION ARE AVAILABLE TO
THOSE WHO ARE LEAST ABLE TO
ACCESS THESE, INCLUDING LOWER,
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES,
RENTERS, AND PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
MULTIFAMILY HOUSING. AND THAT
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE IS
SUFFICIENT TO SUPPORT TRUCK AND
VEHICLE DELIVERY FLEETS AND
SMALL BUSINESSES, REQUIRES ON
THE GROUND KNOWLEDGE IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE CRUCIAL PARTNERS
IN MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE NEEDS OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES THE BEST AND
BECAUSE LOCAL PLANNING IS
NECESSARY TO PLAN FOR THE
ELECTRIC TRANSMISSION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF ALL
COMMUNITIES. WE ALWAYS SAY IN
THE CLIMATE SPACE THAT THIS IS
AN ALL HANDS ON DECK CRISIS THAT
WE'RE DEALING WITH, AND WE NEED
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
INVOLVED. AB 1176 EMBRACES LOCAL
DECISION MAKING AND REQUIRES
HIGH LEVEL PLANNING AND
STRATEGIES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
MEET THE ELECTRIFICATION NEEDS
OF OUR COMMUNITIES, RESIDENTS,
VISITORS, EMPLOYEES AND
BUSINESSES. LASTLY, RECENT
AMENDMENTS. WE TOOK A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
TO ADDRESS THE, CONCERNS OF
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND MANY CITIES
JURISDICTIONS. AND THEN WE TOOK
ON THIS SIDE RECENT AMENDMENTS
TO LIMIT THIS TO JURISDICTIONS
WITH 75,000 RESIDENTS OR MORE,
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
IMPOSING HARDSHIPS ON SOME OF
THE SMALLEST JURISDICTIONS, WITH
ME TODAY IS MELISSA ROMERO OF
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
TO ASSIST WITH QUESTIONS AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
GOOD MORNING. MELISSA ROMERO,
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS,
I WANT TO REMIND YOU OF THIS.
TWO MINUTES. OF COURSE, I JUST
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
OF BIR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE, ENVIRO VOTERS IS
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
1176. WE KNOW THAT
ELECTRIFICATION IS HAPPENING IN
OUR STATE, AND OUR STATE HAS
ADOPTED AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS
THAT REQUIRE DRASTIC CUTS IN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN ALL
THE DIFFERENT SECTORS.
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES TO
DEPLOYING EV CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION HAVE CAUSED SOME
GAPS BASED ON RACE AND INCOME IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THIS TRANSITION,
A PATCHWORK OF STATE INITIATIVES
AND LOCAL ORDINANCES HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO SLOW OR
INCOMPLETE ELECTRIFICATION.
ASIAN AND WITH WEALTHIER
CALIFORNIANS TRANSITIONING AND
BENEFITING FROM THE FIRST
RETROFITS, NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
EV CHARGING ACCESS SO LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES, RENTERS AND
MULTI-FAMILY HOMES ARE FACING
SIGNIFICANT COST BARRIERS TO
ADOPTING EFFICIENT AND
ELECTRIFIED BUILDING
TECHNOLOGIES. PUBLIC CHARGING
ACCESS AND STRATEGIES TO
FACILITATE ELECTRIFICATION IN
RENTAL AND MULTIFAMILY HOMES ARE
CRUCIAL FOR ENSURING AN
EQUITABLE ELECTRIFICATION
TRANSITION. WE'RE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT AB 1176 BECAUSE IT
PROMOTES PROACTIVE MEASURES TO
ENSURING THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE PREPARED FOR THOSE CHANGES
AND KNOW THAT THEY ARE COMING,
AND THIS BILL DOES NOT PROMOTE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION, BUT
RATHER IT LEANS INTO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THEIR
MUNICIPALITIES TO IDENTIFY WHAT
THOSE SOLUTIONS ARE THAT WORK
BEST FOR THEM. AND WITH THAT, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE? YOU HAVE? IS THIS
YOUR YOUR WITNESS? SHE WAS MY
WITNESS. YES. OKAY. THANK YOU.
OKAY. SO NOW WE'LL HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YES. THANK
YOU, DAN SCHORR, ON BEHALF OF
FELLOW EV CHARGING AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. KAI COOPER, ON BEHALF
OF CALSTART AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND CHEN VON Dð, CHAIR OF
THE YOLO COUNTY CLIMATE ACTION
COMMISSION, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SEEING NO MORE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. DILLON ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF
OF THE KERN COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
APPRECIATING THE COMMITTEE'S
EFFORTS IN CONSIDERING THE BILL,
SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT TO THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE INCREASED
TIME AND RESOURCES THAT
IMPLEMENTATION WOULD REQUIRE IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AS
POINTED OUT, MANY OF THE
RECENTLY ENACTED LAWS GOVERNING
INCREASED PLANNING REQUIREMENTS
FALL TO THE SAME LOCAL
GOVERNMENT STAFF, LEADING TO A
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON ULTIMATELY
REALIZING THIS BILL'S STATED
GOALS. IT'S KERN'S OPINION THAT
THIS BILL IS CERTAIN TO
EXACERBATE THAT OUTCOME, GIVEN
IMPLEMENTATION REQUIRES HIGHLY
TECHNICAL, CUMBERSOME, AND
COSTLY EFFORTS, AND FOR THAT
REASON, KERN MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION? OKAY.
SEEING NONE, COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, SENATOR? YES HI. GOOD
MORNING. SO THE OPPOSITION
BROUGHT UP SOME POINTS AND I
THINK YOU CAN SUM THEM UP SOME
WHAT HIS CONCERNS ARE IS THAT
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THIS PLAN,
WHAT ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO PLAN
IN THEIR GENERAL PLAN TO
ELECTRIFY? ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
NEW HOUSING CONSTRUCTION? ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT EXISTING
HOUSING AND TRYING TO RETROFIT
EVERYTHING? SO IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE IN THE
GENERAL PLAN. SO PART OF THE
FLEXIBILITY IS THAT IT CAN BE IN
ANOTHER PLAN FOR EXAMPLE, THE
CITY OF OAKLAND, THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA HAVE ACTUALLY
VOLUNTARILY DONE THESE KINDS OF
PLANS. IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
THEY'VE DONE, WHAT IT DOES IS IT
CREATES STRATEGIES FOR
INCREASING ELECTRIFICATION FOR
BOTH VEHICLE CHARGING IN THEIR
JURISDICTION. SO THEY INCLUDE
POLICIES, FOR EXAMPLE, THAT THEY
WOULD ACTUALLY EMPLOY WHEN THEY
HAVE DISCRETIONARY DECISIONS
COMING BEFORE THEM. THEY THINK
THROUGH WHETHER OR NOT YOU KNOW,
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO PROVIDE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING FOR
PEOPLE THAT ACTUALLY LIVE IN
APARTMENT BUILDINGS. THEY PLAN
OUT AREAS IN THE THAT THAT WHEN
THEY GET PLANT, WHEN THEY GET
FUNDING THAT THEY COULD PROVIDE
ON STREET CHARGING, THEY'RE
THINKING LONG TERM ABOUT
PROVIDING THE VEHICLE CHARGING
THAT THEIR COMMUNITIES NEED. AND
IT'S BASICALLY A PLANNING
EXERCISE. SO SIMILAR TO EVERY
OTHER KIND OF PLANNING EXERCISE
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DO.
RIGHT. AND SO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHO WANT TO DO
THIS ARE ALREADY DOING IT, MY
PROBLEM WITH SOME BILLS LIKE
THIS IS WHEN IT STARTS OUT WITH
THIS BILL REQUIRES CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO DO THIS. IT PUTS
THEM ON A TIMELINE THAT MAY NOT
BE, ATTAINABLE TO THEM, AS
OPPOSED TO OTHERS, ALSO, YOU
KNOW, THE WHOLE EFFORT WITH THE
WHAT I CALL A VERY UNREALISTIC
EFFORT INSTEAD OF ADJUSTING TO
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
ACHIEVE OVER A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME, IT TRANSLATES INTO A VERY
UNAFFORDABLE FUTURE FOR
EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA,
INCLUDING MY KIDS. I'M TIRED OF
HAVING TO WATCH KIDS MOVE OUT OF
THE STATE. AND THIS IS PART OF
IT. THESE TYPE OF BILLS THAT
CONTINUE TO RAISE COSTS FOR
EVERYBODY INCREASE, YOU KNOW,
WHEN YOU'RE INCREASING WORK AT
THE CITIES TO DO PLANS LIKE
THIS. AND THEN THOSE PLANS TURN
INTO MANDATES FOR PEOPLE TO
SPEND MORE MONEY ON THEIR
EXISTING HOMES TO GET THEM OUT
OF THEIR GAS STOVES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT. BECAUSE ALL THOSE
HOUSES, WHEN YOU PUT EVERYTHING
INTO ELECTRICAL, IF YOU TRY TO
ELECTRIFY ALL OF THESE HOUSES,
WHETHER YOU HAVE 1950S OR 40S OR
60 STOCK HOMES, THEY ALL THEY
HAVE TO BE RE REAL. THEY'RE
THEY'RE REAL. THE WIRING HAS TO
BE REDONE IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
BE ABLE TO ACCEPT THE AMOUNT OF
ELECTRICITY THAT IS GOING TO BE
USED IN A HOUSEHOLD THAT IS ALL
ELECTRIC. THERE IS A LOT MORE TO
THIS THAN JUST SAYING, HEY, MAKE
A PLAN. AND I THINK IT'S UP TO
THE CITIES TO, TO DETERMINE WHEN
THEIR COMMUNITY IS READY AND
ABLE TO DO THIS TYPE OF THING.
AND I DON'T THINK THE STATE
SHOULD BE IMPOSING THESE TYPE OF
MANDATES ON CITIES. SO I WILL BE
OPPOSING THIS BILL AS I WILL A
BUNCH OF THE OTHER BILLS THAT
COME THROUGH THAT ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO INCREASE COSTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS, TO THE POINT WHERE
WE'RE LOSING CALIFORNIANS THAT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO HELP OUR TAX
BASE. AND, AND WE'RE WE'RE
LOSING OUR KIDS. OUR KIDS CAN'T
AFFORD ANYTHING HERE. THEY CAN'T
AFFORD HOUSES THAT ARE ALL
ELECTRIFIED LIKE THIS, OR HAVING
TO BUY A HOUSE THAT HAS TO GET
ELECTRIFIED AND SPEND AN
ADDITIONAL $30,000 ON THOSE TYPE
OF THINGS. SO I THINK WE NEED TO
LAY OFF ON SOME OF THIS, AND I
THINK WE NEED TO LET LET
TECHNOLOGY CATCH UP AND THE
MARKET CATCH UP. AND THAT WILL
HELP US DO A SMOOTHER TRANSITION
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THIS IS NOT A
SMOOTH TRANSITION. PEOPLE ARE
FEELING IT AND THEY'RE SICK AND
TIRED OF IT. THANK YOU. I
RESPOND TO THAT. YES. GO AHEAD.
SO FIRST OF ALL, THIS GIVES
CITIES AND TOWNS GREAT
FLEXIBILITY. THE COMPLIANCE
DEADLINE ISN'T UNTIL 2029. IT'S
NOT A YEAR OR TWO OUT. IT'S MANY
YEARS OUT. SO YOU HAVE GREAT
FLEXIBILITY IN DOING THAT. I
WOULD SORT OF PUSH BACK ON THE
ASSERTION THAT THIS IS GOING TO,
RAISE COSTS FOR CONSUMERS. I
MEAN, ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK WHEN YOU ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THE MOVE TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS
THAT I SPEND A LOT LESS ON MY
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS WITH AN
ELECTRIC VEHICLE THAT I WOULD IF
A GAS VEHICLE. AND WHAT THIS
DOES DO IS IT REQUIRES THAT
LOCAL, FIRST OF ALL, IT GIVES
CITIES GREAT FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF HOW THEY DO THIS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. BUT SECOND, IT
ALSO, MAKES SURE THAT THEY'RE
THINKING ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THAT, THAT CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR EVERYONE AT ALL
INCOME LEVELS WHEREVER THEY
LIVE. AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WILL NOT INCREASE COSTS. IT WILL
REDUCE COSTS, BECAUSE IF WE HAVE
PUBLIC CHARGING STATIONS IN
PLACES WHERE PEOPLE CAN ACCESS
THEM, THEY DON'T HAVE TO PUT
THEM IN IN THEIR OWN
JURISDICTIONS. AND IT ALLOWS
FOLKS TO BASICALLY THINK ABOUT
WHEN A SHOPPING CENTER GOES IN,
THINKING ABOUT PUTTING CHARGERS
THERE. MOST OF THOSE ARE GOING
TO PROBABLY BE, YOU KNOW,
PRIVATE, FOR PROFIT THINGS THAT
WON'T REQUIRE A LOT OF COSTS.
BUT IF YOU'RE NOT THINKING ABOUT
THOSE THINGS, THEN AND WE
ALREADY HAVE MANDATES THAT ARE
IN THE LAW, WE HAVE MANDATES
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE SELLING
ONLY ELECTRIC VEHICLES BY 2035.
WE HAVE TO TAKE THE STEPS TO
PLAN FOR THEM AND IMPLEMENT THEM
. SO, ANY MORE WIENER LOST OUR
QUORUM AGAIN. I KNOW WHEN SHE
GETS BACK, WE'RE JUMPING ON IT,
JUST, I, I APPRECIATE THAT THE
TIME FRAME HERE IS UNTIL 2029. I
THINK THAT'S, GIVES TIMING OF
IT, BUT WE DO GET THROUGH HERE A
LOT IS ANOTHER RESPONSIBILITY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND THEY'RE NOT
EXACTLY ALL COORDINATED. RIGHT.
SO WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
HAS BECOME OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT LEVEL. SO ON THAT
SIDE, I AGREE THAT WE HAVE TO BE
CAREFUL HOW AND WHAT WE EXPECT,
IF YOU COULD TOUCH ANY MORE ON
THAT IN TERMS OF YOUR EFFORTS TO
NOT JUST PILE ON, AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND MAKE SURE THAT, YOU
KNOW, THEY REALLY, TRULY HAVE
THE ABILITY BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A LOT OF ISSUES
THAT COME BEFORE THEM. RIGHT?
HOUSING REQUIREMENTS, CLIMATE
REQUIREMENTS, THERE ARE ALL
SORTS OF THINGS. SO IF YOU COULD
, TOUCH ON THAT AND YOUR
RESPONSE, IT'S A VERY LEGITIMATE
CONCERN. SO ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DID IN TERMS OF THE LONG
COMPLIANCE DEADLINE WAS THAT WE
ACTUALLY PUT THAT IN SO THAT
JURISDICTIONS CAN ACTUALLY DO
THIS WHEN THEY'RE DOING OTHER
PLANNING EXERCISES, AND THEY
HAVE THEY CAN PUSH THOSE THINGS
IN. WE DID TAKE MANY CHANGES
FROM CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS
THE STATE IN THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE WERE NOT
SPECIFIC MANDATES, THAT THESE
WERE GUIDELINES THAT THEY WERE
ONES THAT ALLOWED LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO FIT THE WHAT
THEY WERE DOING TO THEIR THE
LOCAL NEEDS. AND I WILL SAY THAT
THE ONLY OPPOSITION AT THIS
POINT IS KERN COUNTY. WE HAVE
THE ALL THE LEAGUE OF CITIES IS
NOW IN A NEUTRAL POSITION BASED
ON OUR HARD WORK WITH THEM, AND
THAT WAS, YOU KNOW, IN ADDITION
TO RAISING THIS TO 75,000, IT
WAS BASICALLY LOOKING CAREFULLY
AND TAKING MANY, MANY AMENDMENTS
THAT THEY ASKED FOR IN TERMS OF
THE CRITERION ON HOW THESE, ON
HOW THESE PLANS, YOU KNOW, NEED
TO MEET AND ACTUALLY SHOWING
THEM EXAMPLES WHERE, WHERE SOME
CITIES HAVE ACTUALLY ALREADY
TAKEN AND DONE THIS VOLUNTARILY
IN THE STATE, AND I THINK WHEN
PEOPLE REALIZE WHAT THIS IS,
THEY REALIZE THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS THAT IS DOABLE
AND IS CONSISTENT WITH THEIR
NORMAL PLANNING ACTIVITIES. AND
IF IT'S ALREADY DONE IN SOME
WAY, SHAPE OR FORM, THEY DON'T
HAVE TO. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL. REINVENT THE
WHEEL. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IF THERE'S NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, YOU CAN
MAKE YOUR CLOSING REMARKS, I
AGAIN, I THINK THE ONLY WE'VE
WE'VE TAKEN ALL OPPOSITION OFF,
OTHER THAN KERN COUNTY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. GREAT. ALL RIGHT. WE WON'T BE
TAKING A VOTE RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. COMMENTS OKAY.
OKAY. NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN. WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING. I'M SHORTER THAN
MR. ZUBAIR. GOOD MORNING, GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS, I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF, AS
ALWAYS, FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL AND MAKE CLEAR THAT
I'M ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TODAY. I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 2085. THIS BILL
STREAMLINES THE DEVELOPMENT FOR
NECESSARY REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE CLINICS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THESE CLINICS
WOULD BE IN AREAS ALREADY ZONED
FOR OFFICE, RETAIL, HEALTH CARE
OR PARKING. USAGES. AS A STATE,
CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED LEGAL
PROTECTIONS FOR ABORTION.
HOWEVER, WE KNOW THAT ACROSS THE
STATE, ACCESS REQUIRES BOTH
LEGAL PROTECTION AND PHYSICAL
ACCESS TO THE HEALTH CARE
ITSELF. UNFORTUNATELY, WE'VE
SEEN CITIES AND COUNTIES BLOCK
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THESE
CLINICS THROUGH BAD FAITH
REQUIREMENTS AND UNNECESSARY
REGULATORY HURDLES. CITIES ARE
PREVENTING BASIC HEALTH CARE
PROVISION IN AREAS THAT ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO RECEIVE
ADEQUATE HEALTH CARE ACCESS. AND
LET ME BE CLEAR, IN SOME PARTS
OF OUR STATE, THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE, WHETHER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PRENATAL CARE OR
STD OR THE LIKE. AND SO FOR
COMMUNITIES TO COME IN AND BLOCK
CLINICS THAT WILL PROVIDE THIS
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE IS REALLY A
DETRIMENT TO THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES. AB 2085 REQUIRES
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL OF CLINICS
THAT MEET ALL OF THE LOCALITY
STANDARDS, ENDING THE ARBITRARY
OBSTRUCTION OF THIS LIFE SAVING
CARE. WITH ME TODAY IS MOLLY
ROBISON WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND ELENA
CHÁVEZ FROM TRAINING IN EARLY
ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE OF
HEALTH CARE. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING. AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. OKAY, GREAT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
ELENA CHÁVEZ, AND I'M THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR TEACH, WHICH
STANDS FOR TRAINING AND EARLY
ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE. AND WE ARE PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF 20 AB 2085. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY FOR THIS
CRITICAL BILL. WHEN I WAS 17
YEARS OLD, I HAD MY FIRST
PREGNANCY SCARE A SENIOR IN HIGH
SCHOOL, I KNEW IMMEDIATELY THAT
IF I WAS TRULY PREGNANT THAT I
DID NOT WANT TO BE FEELING
SCARED AND ALONE. I LOOKED UP
ABORTION NEAR ME ON MY FAMILY'S
DESKTOP COMPUTER. I FELT SICK
WHEN THE RESULTS CAME UP 49.4
MILES AWAY, A 54 MINUTE DRIVE
AND A ONE AND A HALF OR AN HOUR
AND A HALF MINUTE BUS RIDE. HOW
COULD I POSSIBLY GET THERE WITH
NO MONEY, NO CAR, AND TWO
AMAZING BUT OVERLY INVOLVED
PARENTS? AS THE WEEKS WENT BY, I
GREW MORE AND MORE SCARED AND
ISOLATED MYSELF FROM MY FAMILY
AND FRIENDS. LUCKILY, I
EVENTUALLY STARTED MENSTRUATING
AND IT FELT LIKE THE BIGGEST
WEIGHT WAS FINALLY LIFTED OFF MY
SHOULDERS. HOWEVER, I WAS JUST
ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES. YOU SEE,
MY HOMETOWN HAS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST STI AND THE HIGHEST TEEN
PREGNANCY RATES IN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. BY THE TIME I
GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL, 15 OF MY
PEERS WERE ALREADY PARENTS WITH
MANY MORE WALKING ACROSS THE
STAGE TO ACCEPT THEIR DIPLOMAS.
WHY? BECAUSE MY HOMETOWN HAS
LITTLE TO NO OTHER OPTIONS FOR
CARE THAN CRISIS PREGNANCY
CENTERS OR FAKE CLINICS THAT
PROMOTE ABSTINENCE ONLY SEX
EDUCATION AND LIE TO PEOPLE,
TYPICALLY WHO ARE POOR AND OR
BIPOC, ABOUT THE FULL
AVAILABILITY OF THE PREGNANCY
OPTIONS. AS I'M SURE YOU'RE
WONDERING BY NOW WHERE I'M FROM
AND I'M PROUD TO BE FROM
VISALIA, CALIFORNIA, THE GATEWAY
TO THE SEQUOIAS. SO THAT'S WHY
I'M HERE TODAY, TO SHOW YOU HOW
HARMFUL A LACK OF REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE WAS YEARS AGO FOR
PEOPLE IN RURAL AND MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED PARTS OF THE STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY, HOWEVER, NOT MUCH
HAS CHANGED. TO THIS DAY,
VISALIA STILL DOES NOT HAVE AN
ABORTION PROVIDER OR CLINIC TO
PROVIDE THIS CARE, IN FACT, WHEN
I LOOK UP WHEN I LOOKED UP,
VISALIA ABORTION JUST YESTERDAY,
THE FIRST THING THAT POPS UP IS
A FAKE CLINIC WHERE THEY LIE
ABOUT MEDICATION ABORTION BEING
REVERSIBLE. IN FACT, WHEN A NEW
CLINIC WAS TRYING TO OPEN UP IN
VISALIA, LOCAL OPPOSITION
PREVENTED CLINIC CONSTRUCTION
FROM BEGINNING, LEAVING MANY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WITHOUT
ACCESS TO CARE. AND VISALIA IS
NOT THE ONLY LOCATION THIS HAS
HAPPENED IN. THIS HAS BEEN
HAPPENING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN MORE RURAL AREAS LIKE
FONTANA, CALIFORNIA, THAT ARE
ALREADY HEALTH CARE ACCESS
DESERTS. COULD YOU PLEASE WRAP
IT UP? OKAY. SORRY, SO THAT'S
WHY AB 2085 IS NEEDED NOW MORE
THAN EVER. AB 2085 EXPANDS
HEALTHCARE ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES BY CREATING A MORE
STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR CLINIC
CONSTRUCTION TO ADDRESS THE
DIFFICULTIES MANY HEALTH CENTERS
HAVE FACED WHEN OPENING NEW
CLINICS, THAT'S WHY I'M HERE
ASKING FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMING. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR DURAZO AND
MEMBERS. I'M MOLLY ROBSON, I'M
VICE PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA, WHERE
WE REPRESENT THE SEVEN
AFFILIATES IN THE STATE WHO
OPERATE OVER 100 HEALTH CENTERS
AND SERVE PROVIDE SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE TO
ALMOST A MILLION PATIENTS
ANNUALLY. PLANNED PARENTHOOD IS
SPONSORING AB 2085 TO STREAMLINE
THE PERMITTING PROCESS. AS YOU
JUST HEARD, SINCE THE DOBBS
DECISION TWO YEARS AGO, WE'VE
SEEN ATTACKS ON ABORTION,
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE, GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE AND BIRTH CONTROL
ALL INTENSIFY, TRANSFORMING
HEALTH CARE INTO POLITICAL
BATTLEGROUNDS, WHICH HAS
DANGEROUS CONSEQUENCES. EVEN IN
CALIFORNIA, WE'VE SEEN THESE
ATTACKS IN ACTION. FOR EXAMPLE,
AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED IN THE
CITY OF FONTANA, THE LOCAL
PLANNED PARENTHOOD RECEIVED
VERBAL APPROVAL TO CONSTRUCT A
NEW CLINIC ON A VACANT SITE
ALREADY ZONED FOR HEALTH CARE
AFTER FOLLOWING STANDARD
PROCEDURE, ABIDING BY ALL LOCAL
GUIDELINES AND ADJUSTING AS
NEEDED TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH
LOCAL PLANNING STANDARDS. IT WAS
A SURPRISE WHEN, AFTER A YEAR OF
PLANNING, THE CITY COUNCIL
PLACED A TEMPORARY MORATORIUM ON
ANY NEW BUILDINGS IN THE AREA.
THE COUNCIL THEN PLACED ANOTHER
MORATORIUM, THIS TIME FOR TEN
MONTHS, WHICH HAS NOW BEEN
DETERMINED TO ONLY IMPACT THE
HEALTH CENTER. IN A POST DOBBS
ERA WHEN MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HAVE
LOST ACCESS TO ABORTION AND
OTHER REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
IN THEIR HOME STATES, IT IS
CRITICAL THAT IN CALIFORNIA,
ACCESS IS NOT IMPEDED. THE
FONTANA HEALTH CENTER, FOR
EXAMPLE, WOULD HAVE PROVIDED AN
ESTIMATED 2000 MEDICAL VISITS
PER MONTH AND POSITIVELY
IMPACTED THE COMMUNITY, YET
REMAINS ON HOLD. AB 2085 ENSURES
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CANNOT
UNJUSTLY INTERFERE WITH THE
DELIVERY OF HEALTH CARE, AND
DELIVERS ON CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT AS A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS? AB 2085
MARTIN RADOSEVICH, ON BEHALF OF
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR ALL.
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR MEMBERS
BRADY GARDNER, ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES, IN
A SUPPORTIVE, AMENDED POSITION
LOOKING FOR THE ABILITY TO
SEPARATE FROM SENSITIVE AREAS AS
WELL AS AN EXTENSION OF
REVIEWING A COMPLETED
APPLICATION DEADLINE FROM 60 TO
90 DAYS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, MEGAN SUBERS ON BEHALF
OF CPCA ADVOCATES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GENESIS GONZALEZ, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, KATHY
MOSSBERG ON BEHALF OF APLA
HEALTH AND ESSENTIAL ACCESS,
BOTH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BRIANNA NELSON ON BEHALF OF
TEACH IN STRONG SUPPORT AS
CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE, ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS GREG BURT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB 2085. WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL UNDERMINES
THAT. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. YOU
HAVE TWO. THANK YOU, WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL UNDERMINES LOCAL
CONTROL AND INFRINGES UPON
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY AND UNJUSTLY
GIVES SPECIAL PRIVILEGES TO
ABORTION FACILITIES, WHICH
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF. WHILE NEGLECTING
THE NEEDS FOR MORE PRENATAL AND
MATERNITY CARE. THIS BILL WOULD
FORCE MUNICIPALITIES TO, OPEN
ABORTION FACILITIES AS A RIGHT
AND PERMITS LAWSUITS AGAINST
THOSE THAT DON'T COMPLY. THIS
OVERREACH CIRCUMVENTS THE LOCAL
CITY COUNCILS THAT HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DECIDE WHICH BUSINESSES
ARE PERMITTED WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS. JUST AS CITIES
REGULATE LOCAL, THE LOCATION OF
TOBACCO AND LIQUOR STORES OR
CASINOS, THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
RIGHT TO DECIDE WHERE ABORTION
FACILITIES GO. ABORTION IS NOT
JUST ANOTHER HEALTH CARE
SERVICE. IT'S A PROFOUND MORAL
ISSUE DESERVING THE HIGHEST
SCRUTINY AND LOCAL DISCRETION BY
FORCING MUNICIPALITIES TO ACCEPT
ABORTION FACILITIES, THE STATE
IMPOSES A PARTICULAR MORAL VIEW
AND DISCRIMINATES AGAINST
REPRODUCTIVE CARE THAT IS
CRITICALLY NEEDED. 1 IN 4 WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA RECEIVED
INADEQUATE PRENATAL CARE. 46
MATERNITY WARDS HAVE CLOSED DOWN
SINCE 2012, AND THE MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATES ARE INCREASING.
IT IS INCONCEIVABLE TO
PRIORITIZE THE EXPANSION OF
ABORTION FACILITIES WHILE
NEGLECTING ESSENTIAL MATERNITY
AND PRENATAL SERVICES. IT'S
UNETHICAL TO MANDATE ABORTION
CLINICS IN COMMUNITIES THAT LACK
ADEQUATE FACILITIES TO SUPPORT
PREGNANT WOMEN. WOMEN IN RURAL
AREAS FACE SEVERE CHALLENGES IN
ACCESSING QUALITY PRE, MATERNITY
CARE, AND THIS BILL DOES NOTHING
TO ADDRESS THOSE DISPARITIES.
IT'S LIKE YOU DON'T WANT WOMEN
TO HAVE BABIES IN CERTAIN AREAS,
WE SHOULD BE REJOICING AT
PREGNANCIES, NOT TREATING UNBORN
BABIES LIKE A DEADLY DISEASE
THAT NEED ABORTION AS A CURE.
ABORTION IS A VIOLENT ANSWER TO
THAT HARMS BOTH THE CHILD AND
THE MOTHER. AND CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE BETTER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. OH.
OKAY. YES COME FORWARD, PASTOR
BRANDON CAMPBELL, NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA, DIRECTOR OF BAPTISTS
FOR BIBLICAL VALUES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. OKAY.
WE'LL COME BACK HERE. ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS? OKAY.
SEEING NONE, YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT AS SOMEONE WHO
HAS HAD THREE PREGNANCIES, ALL
OF WHICH I CONSIDERED INCREDIBLY
JOYFUL, AND I CELEBRATED EVERY
ONE WHO WAS LUCKY TO LIVE IN THE
BAY AREA, WHERE I HAD ACCESS TO
INCREDIBLE PRENATAL CARE AND
NEEDED IT EVERY SINGLE TIME, AS
EVERY WOMAN DOES. I THINK THAT
THE OPPOSITION MADE MY POINT FOR
ME ABOUT THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
PRENATAL CARE ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THESE COMMUNITY CLINICS DO A LOT
MORE THAN PROVIDE ACCESS TO
ABORTION, AND THE BLOCKAGE OF
THEM IS HARMING OUR, OUR FUTURE
AND OUR COMMUNITIES. SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY, BUT WE CAN'T
CAN'T ACCEPT IT UNTIL WE TAKE
THE QUORUM. OKAY. HOLD ON, HOLD
ON. ALL RIGHT. YOU'RE LUCKY
WE'RE GONNA TAKE QUORUM.
SENATORS DURAZZO HERE. DURAZZO
PRESENT. SUGIARTO. SUGIARTO.
PRESENT. DOLLY. GLASER MÀ.
GLASER. PRESENT. SKINNER. WAHAB
WIENER. WIENER. PRESENT. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY, NOW WE'LL
TAKE. WE HAVE SEVEN MEMBERS. WE
HAVE SEVEN. I MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY. THE BILL, AB 2085 HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR WIENER. WE'LL
NOW TAKE THE VOTE. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. SENATORS DURAZZO, I
DURAZZO I SATO. SATO. NO. DOLLY
GLASER. GLASER I SKINNER. WAHAB
WIENER. WIENER I 3 TO 1. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. WE'LL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS.
OKAY. WE WILL GO BACK TO. OH,
NO. LET'S WAIT UNTIL. SHALL WE
WAIT FOR SENATOR WAHAB TO VOTE
ON THE OTHER ONE?
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO BACK AND
TAKE A VOTE. WE'LL GO BACK TO
THE MOTION ON NINE. OKAY. WE
STARTED WITH YES. OKAY. A B
2715. WE NEED A MOTION. SENATOR
GLASER MOVES, AB 2715, TAKE THE
VOTE. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATORS
DURAZZO, A DURAZZO. AYE. SATO.
SATO. AYE. DOLLY GLASER. GLASER.
AYE. SKINNER. WAHAB WIENER.
WIENER. AYE. 4 TO 0. OKAY. LEAVE
THAT OPEN. WE'LL GO BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE. AB 817. WE NEED WE
NEED A MOTION. THIS IS. THIS IS
THE CHAIR VOTING. NOW NO MOTION.
THERE'S NO MOTION. OKAY. NO
MOTION. I WANT A COURTESY. I'M
ASKING FOR A NO OR. THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S OKAY. CONSIDERATION OKAY,
OKAY. WE HAVE A MOTION MOVED BY
SENATOR WIENER. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE AND
JUDICIARY. SENATORS DURAZZO. NO
DURAZZO. NO. SATO. SATO. NO.
DOLLY GLASER. GLASER. NO.
SKINNER WAHAB. WIENER 3 TO 0.
OKAY HOLD IT OPEN. 0 TO 3.
CORRECTION THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN, NEXT IS
ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB 1176. WE
NEED A MOTION, SIR. THANK YOU.
MOVE BY SENATOR GLASER. MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENERGY, UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS. SENATORS DURAZZO
A DURAZZO. AYE. SATO. SATO NO.
DOLLY. GLASER. GLASER. AYE
SKINNER. WAHAB. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. WIENER. AYE. 4 TO 1.
WE'LL HOLD THAT OPEN AND THAT'S
IT. YOU CAN ADD. WE CAN ADD.
WE'LL GO BACK, AND WE'LL GO BACK
ON ALL THE BILLS SO FAR ON FOUR.
OKAY. AB ITEM NINE, AB 2715.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE AND JUDICIARY. CURRENT
VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS DOLLY
SKINNER, WAHAB WAHAB. AYE, FIVE
ZERO. LEAVE THAT OPEN. GO TO
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB 817. MOTION
IS TO PASS THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. CURRENT VOTE IS 0 TO
3 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING NO.
SENATORS. DOLLY SKINNER, WAHAB.
WIENER 0 TO 3. OKAY, MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO. AB 1176. WE'LL
LEAVE THAT OTHER OPEN. SHE VOTED
ON THAT ONE. OH, SHE DID OKAY.
WHICH ONE? ON THE BALLOT ON
NUMBER TWO. NOW WE GO TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE OKAY. ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB 2085. MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 1
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS DOLLY SCORE. HONOR.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 4 TO 1. OKAY,
NOW WE MOVE ON TO. WE HAVE ANY
AUTHORS HERE. ADDIS. HOOVER,
MCCARTY. BRIAN IF WE COULD DO A
QUICK RECESS UNTIL. OKAY, WE
HAVE NO OTHERS HERE. WILL TAKE A
QUICK RECESS. AS SOON AS
SOMEBODY GETS HERE. WE'LL TAKE
THEM UP.
Ã. AUTHOR OH, IT'S NOT WORKING.
NO. IT IS. OKAY. OH, WELL. THANK
YOU. TECHNICAL ASSISTANT. WIENER
AS I UNDERSTAND IT, ASSEMBLYMAN
MCCARTY IS HAVING A SPECIAL
PRESENTER HERE TODAY. THE CHAIR
OF OUR COMMITTEE, MARIA ELENA
DURAZO. OH, OKAY. AND WE'D LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE YOU TO PRESENT.
THIS IS SB, THIS IS AB 2593. NO,
NO. OH IT'S ADDIS I THOUGHT UPS
BOY I APOLOGIZE. SIGNALS ARE
GETTING CROSSED HERE ALL OVER
THE PLACE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOUR. IS THAT CORRECT? ASSEMBLY
BILL 2302 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS. CHAIR DEROSA. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU. YES. ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS,
THIS BILL WILL CLARIFY THE
NUMBER OF MEETINGS THAT MEMBERS
OF A LOCAL LEGISLATIVE BODY CAN
PARTICIPATE IN REMOTELY FOR JUST
CAUSE OR EMERGENCY CIRCUMSTANCE
DURING THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC,
LOCAL BODIES FOUND THAT ALLOWING
MEMBERS TO ATTEND MEETINGS
REMOTELY WAS HELPFUL WHEN THEY
HAD DIFFICULTIES ATTENDING IN
PERSON. IN 2022, HB 2449 ALLOWED
MEMBERS OF LEGISLATIVE, LOCAL
LEGISLATIVE BODIES TO
PARTICIPATE IN MEETINGS REMOTELY
UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES, FOR
A MAXIMUM OF 20% OF MEETINGS A
YEAR. CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
SPECIFY WHETHER MULTIPLE
SESSIONS OF A LEGISLATIVE BODY
ON THE SAME DAY SHOULD BE
CLASSIFIED AS ONE MEETING OR TWO
SEPARATE MEETINGS. THIS CREATES
AN UNINTENTIONAL TWO TIERED
SYSTEM WHERE LEGISLATIVE BODIES
ARE TREATED DIFFERENTLY UNDER
THE LAW. AB 2302 WOULD CLARIFY
THE NUMBER OF MEETINGS THAT
MEMBERS OF A LOCAL LEGISLATIVE
BODY CAN PARTICIPATE IN VIA
TELECONFERENCE EACH YEAR, BASED
ON HOW MANY TIMES THE LOCAL BODY
MEETS, AND IT PRESERVES THE
ORIGINAL INTENT OF AB 2449
BECAUSE IT STILL EQUALS ABOUT
20% OF THE LEGISLATURE BODY
MEETINGS EACH YEAR. IT CLARIFIES
THAT THE TERM MEETING MEANS ANY
NUMBER OF MEETINGS OF A
LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATIVE BODY
THAT BEGIN ON THE SAME CALENDAR
DAY. THIS WILL REDUCE CONFUSION
OKAY AROUND EXISTING LAW AND
ENSURE THAT PUBLIC SERVANTS WILL
NOT RECEIVE ANY UNFAIR PENALTIES
WHILE ATTEMPTING TO FOLLOW THE
LAW IN GOOD FAITH AND SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES WITH THIS
TODAY IS DAVE FLESHMAN, CITY
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF PISMO
BEACH. THANK YOU, SENATOR DURAZO
. SO WE'LL HEAR FROM YOUR
WITNESSES. AND I UNDERSTAND IT'S
A TWO MINUTE LIMITATION PER
WITNESS, PER THE CHAIR. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DAVE
FLEISCHMANN. I'M THE CITY
ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF PISMO
BEACH. AND I'M ALSO THE PAST
PRESIDENT OF THE CITY ATTORNEY'S
DEPARTMENT OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PISMO BEACH, I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STEADFAST
SUPPORT OF AB 2302, WHICH WILL
GIVE CITIES LIKE PISMO BEACH
FLEXIBILITY THAT WAS AFFORDED TO
ALL OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
DURING DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE
BROWN ACT IN 2022. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS
FOR HER WILLINGNESS TO AUTHOR
THE LEGISLATION. THE CITY OF
PISMO BEACH IS A SMALL COASTAL
COMMUNITY ON THE CENTRAL COAST
AND PRIDES ITSELF ON
TRANSPARENCY AND PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. THE CITY COUNCIL
HAS ALWAYS ENCOURAGED INPUT FROM
THE RESIDENTS, ESPECIALLY AT
CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS. THIS HAS
LED THE CITY TO CONDUCT BOTH ITS
OPEN AND CLOSED SESSIONS OF THE
CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS. AS
SEPARATE INDIVIDUAL MEETINGS
WITH SEPARATE AGENDAS TO PROVIDE
A MORE PREDICTABLE TIMELINE FOR
THE PUBLIC TO PARTICIPATE. THESE
MEETINGS ARE ALWAYS HELD
CONSECUTIVELY ON THE SAME
EVENING, AND THUS THIS NUANCED
APPROACH HAS SERVED SEVERAL
CITIES WELL. TO MAXIMIZE
TRANSPARENCY. AS YOU KNOW, NEW
LAWS WERE ADOPTED IN 2022 THAT
ADDRESSED VIRTUAL PARTICIPATION
IN CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS.
CAPPING THE NUMBER OF MEETINGS,
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY
CAN PARTICIPATE IN VIRTUALLY.
THIS LANGUAGE WAS NEGOTIATED
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS, WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING AT THE TIME THAT
THEY WOULD BE APPLIED UNIFORMLY
ACROSS ALL PUBLIC AGENCIES.
HOWEVER, SOME INTERPRETATIONS OF
THESE NEW LAWS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT CITIES
LIKE PISMO BEACH, WHO AGENDIZE
AND CONDUCT SEPARATE MEETINGS OF
THE CITY COUNCIL FOR OPEN AND
CLOSED SESSIONS. AS THIS RESULTS
IN A DOUBLE COUNTING OF MEETINGS
IN WHICH MEMBERS OF THE CITY
COUNCIL CAN PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY. AB 2302 SEEKS TO
RECTIFY THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF THESE
COMPREHENSIVE BILLS FROM 2022
AND RESTORE FLEXIBILITY AND
PARITY THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
AFFORDED TO ALL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL IS THE RIGHT APPROACH
TO ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM AND
SIMPLY CLARIFIES THE INTENT FOR
MAYBE 2449 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO IN 2022 UNDER
INTERPRETATION OF CURRENT LAW,
OUR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
PISMO BEACH CAN PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY ONLY HALF THE TIME THAN
WHAT WAS INTENDED. IN ONE
INSTANCE, IT RESULTED IN OUR
MAYOR OPTING TO NOT ATTEND ONE
OF THE MEETINGS TO PRESERVE HIS
ABILITY TO APPEAR REMOTELY AT A
FUTURE MEETING. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF AB 2302,
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. GREAT THANK YOU SIR. ARE
THERE ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO DO A
ME TOO ON THIS BILL IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS. JASON EICHER, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION. ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SYLVIA
SOLIS, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
GOLETA, IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MARTIN RADOSEVICH, ON
BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, JOHNNY PINA WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GREAT. THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION. ARE THEIR MAIN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES HERE.
ANYBODY HERE WHO WANTS TO
INDICATE THEIR POSITION IN
OPPOSITION? ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE. WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS, SEEING NONE,
SENATOR GERARD, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES. ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADDIS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
OKAY. LOOKING FOR A MOTION,
SENATOR WAHAB HAS MOVED THE
BILL, AND IT IS A DUE PASS. TO
WHAT? TO OUR SECRETARY. THE
SENATE FLOOR. THAT'S A DUE PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR MOTION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE FLOOR. SENATOR
DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE. SATO.
DALI DOLLY I. GLASER. GLASER I.
SKINNER WAHAB. WAHHAB I. WIENER
WIENER I 5 TO 0 5 TO 0. WE'LL
PUT IT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ITEM FIVE, AB 2350. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOOVER. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS,
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 2350 TO YOU TODAY AS
A FORMER SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER, WE
ARE JUST, INTRODUCING THIS BILL
AS A SIMPLE CHANGE TO THE BROWN
ACT. ESSENTIALLY, UNDER CURRENT
LAW, IT IS REQUIRED, IN THE
EVENT OF EMERGENCY MEETING TO
CONTACT MEMBERS OF THE PRESS VIA
TELEPHONE. THIS WOULD SIMPLY
ALLOW AN ALTERNATIVE TO THAT TO
CONTACT MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA VIA
EMAIL, FOR THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA THAT OPT IN TO THAT, AND
WE TOOK SOME AMENDMENTS IN THE
ASSEMBLY TO ADDRESS CONCERNS BY
THE FIRST AMENDMENT COALITION.
AND I BELIEVE THE BILL NOW HAS
NO OPPOSITION. WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANY DO
YOU HAVE ANY BODY HERE? I DO NOT
HAVE TESTIMONY. THERE MIGHT BE A
COUPLE PEOPLE MEETING. IS
ANYBODY HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
2350? MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
I'M JENNY LARA WITH FIRST
AMENDMENT COALITION. WE'RE NOT
ON RECORD IN SUPPORT, BUT WE ARE
CONSIDERING MOVING TO SUPPORT,
SO I THOUGHT I WOULD SHARE THAT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
OKAY. SEEING NONE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS HERE ON THE MOTION.
THANK YOU. SENATOR WAHAB. LET'S
TAKE THE VOTE. OH CLOSING
REMARKS I'M SORRY, I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MOTION IS TO
PASS THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO. AYE.
SATO SATO. AYE. DOLLY. DOLLY.
AYE. GLAZER GLAZER. AYE.
SKINNER. WAHAB. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. WIENER. AYE. 6 TO 0.
THANK YOU. LEAVE THAT OPEN.
THANK YOU, NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR.
I MEAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN. AND THAT'S AB
2684. WELCOME YEAH. WHAT WE LIKE
TO SHAKE THINGS UP HERE, YOU
KNOW, KEEP IT SPICY. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
SENATORS, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 2684, A BILL THAT WOULD
REQUIRE CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
ACCOUNT FOR EXTREME HEAT IN
THEIR LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION
PLANS OR SAFETY ELEMENTS. FIRST,
I WANT TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING SO
HARD WITH ME AND MY TEAMS TO
TREAT STRATEGIC PLANNING AND
RESPONSE TO EXTREME HEAT. WILL
ALLOW OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
BE AS PREPARED AS POSSIBLE TO
PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS FROM
EXTREME HEAT. LOOKING AHEAD TO
2050, OVER 200 OF OUR CITIES
WILL BE EXPERIENCING AVERAGE
TEMPERATURES SURPASSING 90°F.
OR, LOOKING BACK TO YESTERDAY,
WHEN IT WAS 106 DEGREES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO, I LOOKED AT MY
WEATHER APP AND IT CALLED IT
SIZZLING SUNSHINE. THE REASON
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PLAN FOR
EXTREME HEAT IN OUR LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLAN IS BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
HAVE ACCESS TO FEMA DOLLARS IN
CASE OF EMERGENCY HEAT OR
EXTREME HEAT EMERGENCIES, WHICH
THEY CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO RIGHT NOW. THE BURDEN FOR
THESE KINDS OF EMERGENCY CRISIS
RESTS SOLELY ON THOSE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND THE STATE. BY
PLANNING FOR THESE KINDS OF
DISASTERS, WE OPEN OURSELVES UP
TO THE ABILITY TO GET OUTSIDE
RESOURCES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, WHICH I THINK IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN A TIME
LIKE NOW WHERE WE'RE FACING SUCH
AN EXTREME BUDGET DEFICIT. THIS
BILL HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. JOINING
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS MICHAEL.
JARED ON BEHALF OF CLIMATE
RESOLVE AND FORMERLY FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROGER DICKERSON,
REPRESENTING CIVIC WELL,
WELCOME, AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS MICHAEL. JARED. AND I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF CLIMATE
RESOLVE. CLIMATE RESOLVE IS A
NONPROFIT BASED IN LOS ANGELES
THAT BUILDS COLLABORATION TO
CHAMPION EQUITABLE CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS. CLIMATE RESOLVE
CONNECTS COMMUNITIES,
ORGANIZATIONS, AND POLICYMAKERS
TO ADDRESS A GLOBAL PROBLEM WITH
LOCAL ACTION. CLIMATE RESOLVE IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 2684, WHICH
SUPPORTS LOCAL PLANNING EFFORTS
ON EXTREME HEAT, ONE OF CLIMATE
RESOLVES AREAS OF FOCUS IS
EXTREME HEAT BECAUSE IT IS A
SILENT KILLER. THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS THE
ELDERLY, CHILDREN, LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS, THOSE WITH
PREEXISTING MEDICAL CONDITIONS
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
EXTREME HEAT IS GROWING IN
INTENSITY. WE CAN SEE THAT TODAY
, FREQUENCY AND DURATION IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT PREPARED.
EXTREME HEAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MORE DEATHS THAN ANY OTHER
DISASTER IN CALIFORNIA. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS RECOGNIZED THE
IMPACT OF EXTREME HEAT, BY
ESTABLISHING THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH'S EXTREME
HEAT COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
PROGRAM, A FIRST OF ITS KIND
GRANT PROGRAM TO COMBAT EXTREME
HEAT IN COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT
THE MOST. AND BY CODIFYING THE
EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN LAST
YEAR AND SENATOR CABALLERO'S SB
306, AB 2684 LOOKS TO SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAKING MORE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ELIGIBLE FOR
FEMA PRE HAZARD MITIGATION
FUNDS. EXTREME HEAT IMPACTS SOME
COMMUNITIES EVERY YEAR AND
OTHERS CAN BE IMPACTED IN RARE
EXTREME WEATHER. HEAT DOMES.
CLIMATE RESOLVE BELIEVES IT IS
GOOD GOVERNMENT FOR EVERY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO PLAN FOR EXTREME
HEAT. AB 2684 WOULD OPEN UP NEW
FUNDING CHANNELS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PLAN AND
IMPLEMENT TRANSFORMATIVE AND
RESILIENT INFRASTRUCTURE ADAPTED
TO RISING TEMPERATURES. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR. I
VOTE ON AB 2684. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. WELCOME
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M ROGER DICKINSON,
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CIVIC. WELL,
FORMERLY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN HAS DESCRIBED THE BILL
WELL AND WE WANT TO THANK HIM
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. EXTREME HEAT
IS INCREASINGLY A MAJOR ISSUE
FOR COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, AS THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE MANIFEST
THEMSELVES, AS WE NOT ONLY SEE
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND SOUTHEAST
CALIFORNIA ENDURING GROWING
NUMBERS OF EPISODES OF EXTREME
HEAT. BUT CITIES AND COUNTIES
ELSEWHERE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ARE EXPERIENCING THE SAME
PATTERN. EXTREME HEAT CAN CAUSE
PROFOUND CONSEQUENCES FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH, LOCAL ECONOMIES AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US OLDER
POPULATIONS, CHILDREN AND THOSE
WITH HEALTH CONDITIONS FACE THE
GREATEST RISK. HOWEVER, THERE
ARE STEPS WE CAN TAKE TO REDUCE
THE IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT,
INCLUDING APPLYING COOL SURFACES
AND CREATING GREEN SPACES. WE
CAN IMPROVE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND INCREASE CLEAN ENERGY TO
REDUCE HEAT ISLAND EFFECTS AB
2684 WILL ALLOW LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO BUILD ON THE
STATE'S EXTREME HEAT ACTION PLAN
AND EXTREME HEAT AND COMMUNITIES
RESILIENCE PROGRAM THROUGH THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH.
BY INCORPORATING EXTREME HEAT
COMPONENTS IN THE SAFETY ELEMENT
OF THEIR GENERAL PLANS. IN SO
DOING, COMMUNITIES CAN USE
HAZARD MITIGATION PLANNING AND
FUNDING TO ADDRESS EXTREME HEAT
CONDITIONS, AS AB 2684 ALSO
PROVIDES A COMPLEMENT TO SB 852
BY SENATOR DODD FROM 2022, WHICH
CIVIC WELL CO-SPONSORED THAT
AUTHORIZES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ESTABLISH CLIMATE RESILIENCE
DISTRICTS. AB 2684 ADDRESSES A
MAJOR THREAT TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU AND THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DICKINSON. OKAY,
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
2684? UNLESS THIS BILL HIGH WITH
THE CITY OF CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. SEEING NO
MORE IN SUPPORT. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? HI. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. ANGIE
MINETTI HERE, TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY, OUR POSITION
IS OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. I KNOW
THE ANALYSIS HAS IS STATED AS
OPPOSITION, WE ARE SIMPLY ASKING
THAT WHEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
UPDATE THEIR SAFETY ELEMENT TO
ADDRESS EXTREME HEAT, THAT IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE LAW THAT WAS
PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE IN
2002. AB 209. THAT LAW REQUIRED
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO SUBMIT
BY JANUARY 1ST, 2025
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE, WHICH WERE DESIGNED
TO ENSURE THAT RESIDENTIAL
DWELLING UNITS CAN MAINTAIN A
SAFE INDOOR AIR TEMPERATURE. WE
ASK THAT THE MANDATE IN AB 2684
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE HCD
RECOMMENDATIONS. THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE INTENDED TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT METHODS FOR
REDUCING INDOOR AIR TEMPERATURE,
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO,
BUILDING AND SITE ELECTRICAL
SYSTEM LIMITATIONS, COST
BARRIERS, ELECTRIC UTILITY
CAPACITY LIMITATIONS, STATE AND
FEDERAL STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS,
AND OTHER RELEVANT FACTORS. THE
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS FOR
HEAT MITIGATION WILL CERTAINLY
BE COST BARRIERS FOR EXISTING
BUILDINGS AND ELECTRICAL UTILITY
CAPACITY LIMITS. WE BELIEVE OUR
REQUESTED AMENDMENT IS
REASONABLE AND DOES NOT CONFLICT
WITH THE GOAL OF AB 2684. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
OUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE COME BACK TO THE
DAIS? ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS?
SENATOR GLAZER? THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMAN BRYANT, FIRST, LET
ME JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE. I
THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT'S A BIG PROBLEM. AND GETTING
IN FRONT OF IT CERTAINLY AS IT
RELATES TO TRYING TO MATCH IT UP
WITH FEDERAL MONEY, IS THE SMART
THING TO DO, THE ISSUE THAT I'M
CHALLENGED ON THE BILL IS NOT
ABOUT THE GOALS, BUT REALLY IT'S
ABOUT HOW IT'S WEAVED INTO OUR
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE
IN LAW. AND ONE OF THE THINGS I
NOTE IN THIS BILL IS THAT YOUR
EFFECTIVE DATE IS NOT TILL 2028.
IS THAT RIGHT? CORRECT. YEAH. SO
I'M WONDERING, YOU KNOW, THE
SUGGESTION FROM THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IS THAT THEY'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE IT ADHERE TO THESE
HCD REGULATIONS THAT ARE COMING
OUT NEXT YEAR, BUT NOBODY KNOWS
WHAT THEY ARE. AND I KNOW IT'S
YOUR POINT OF I MEAN, THE
ANALYSIS RAISES THE ISSUE OF
DEFINITION AS A CHALLENGE. AND
YOU, I THINK RIGHTLY THROUGH
STAFF, HAVE INDICATED THAT IF
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT HCD IS
SAYING, HOW CAN WE COMPLY WITH
IT. RIGHT. AND SO I THINK THAT'S
A FAIR THAT'S A FAIR POINT TOO,
YET WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S SOME CONSISTENT
PRACTICES AND POLICIES THAT GO
FORWARD TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. I
KNOW FROM MY TIME IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THESE THINGS ARE
NOT YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
A LIGHT SWITCH TO TURN ON. THERE
IS A PROCESS. THERE'S AN EXPENSE
THERE THAT EVERY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS TO GO THROUGH TO
DO THESE THINGS, RIGHTFULLY SO,
BUT WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IF
WE'RE GOING TO DIRECT THEM TO DO
IT, THAT THERE'S SOME
CONSISTENCY AND SO THEY KNOW HOW
TO DO IT. AND THAT WOULD REALLY
BE MY QUESTION TO YOU, GIVEN
THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF
2028, EVEN THOUGH I WON'T BE
AROUND YOU, WILL. WHY NOT, WHY
NOT, WHY NOT PAUSE A DAY? WHY
NOT PAUSE A YEAR ON THIS WORTHY
PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO GET IT RIGHT? YEAH. I
THINK UNFORTUNATELY, OUR OUR
CLIMATE EMERGENCY ISN'T ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WE CAN PAUSE A
YEAR, AS I MENTIONED YESTERDAY,
106 HERE IN SACRAMENTO, EVERY
YEAR WE ARE NOT PLANNING, FOR
URBAN HEAT IS A IS A YEAR THAT
WE ARE FAILING OUR SENIORS. WE
ARE FAILING OUR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. AND WE SHOULD HAVE
STARTED THIS PROCESS A LONG TIME
AGO. IT ALSO IS ANOTHER YEAR
WHERE AN EMERGENCY COULD HAPPEN.
THAT WE CAN'T GET OUTSIDE AID
FOR. EVEN GIVING IT A 2028
DEADLINE GIVES LOCAL
JURISDICTION. WE WANT TO GIVE
THEM THE FLEXIBILITY TO PLAN
OVER TIME AND OVER SPACE, WHICH
IS PART OF WHY NOT KNOWING WHAT
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM HCD
ARE, BOXING THEM IN TO
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT DON'T
EXIST, I THINK IS UNFAIR TO OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. THE NEEDS
OF THE COACHELLA VALLEY MIGHT BE
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT THAN THE
NEEDS OF SAN FRANCISCO, AND SO
DEFINITELY WANT TO MAINTAIN THAT
FLEXIBILITY. I APPRECIATE THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION, AND WE'VE
BEEN IN COMMUNICATION ABOUT THIS
BILL AND OTHERS, AND I THINK WE
WILL STAY IN COMMUNICATION
BECAUSE OUR GOALS ARE ALIGNED.
AND I THINK WE'LL WE'LL FIND
THAT RIGHT LANDING SPOT. I'M NOT
SURE IF IT'S FORCING LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ADHERE TO
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT DON'T EXIST
YET, BUT I WILL BE HERE NEXT
YEAR AND IN 2028 IF THE PEOPLE
WILL HAVE ME. AND SO THIS IS AN
ISSUE I PLAN TO WORK ON THROUGH
MANY ITERATIONS. THIS IS JUST, I
THINK, THE FIRST STEP TO MAKING
SURE THAT OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE PREPARED FOR
WHAT IS HAPPENING, WHAT'S
COMING, AND HAVE THE RESOURCES,
BOTH LOCALLY AND NATIONALLY, TO
DEAL WITH THESE CRISES. IF I
COULD, AND FOLLOW UP AGAIN, I
THINK OUR GOALS ARE ALIGNED. I
GREW UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO, AND
106 IS NOT AN UNUSUAL, AS I WAS
GROWING UP, I CERTAINLY HAD MANY
OF THOSE DAYS, BUT I STILL WE'RE
STILL IN AGREEMENT ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND HOW THIS IS A RISING
PROBLEM. SO FOR SURE, I, YOU
KNOW. I, AND I, I GUESS THAT'S
MY PAUSE. I STILL WANT TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO WITH IT.
IT'S JUST THAT, IT JUST SEEMS
THAT THIS DEFINITION IS CRITICAL
TO MAKING SURE THERE'S
CONSISTENCY. AND THE STATE HAS
RECOGNIZED IN PREVIOUS BILLS
THAT THIS IS A PROBLEM AND
THERE'S REQUIREMENTS. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S ACTION PLAN IS
ADVANCING. SO IT'S NOT LIKE THIS
IS A BRAND NEW WE'RE WAKING UP
AND WE SEE A PROBLEM. SO YOU'RE
TRYING TO WEAVE SOMETHING INTO
WHAT IS AN EXISTING ACTION PLAN
OF THE STATE. WHICH IS FINE.
IT'S JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE CLARITY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND THAT'S JUST THE
PAUSE THAT I GUESS MAKES ME WANT
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL. BUT THAT
HAS SOME, CONCERNS ABOUT MAKING
SURE IT CAN BE IT CAN WORK.
WELL, YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE WORKING THROUGH IT.
OKAY. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE? CAN I HAVE A
MOTION? I'LL MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. SENATOR WAHAB.
CLOSING REMARKS. YEAH FAILING TO
PREPARE IS PREPARING TO FAIL,
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
BEEN FAILING OUR SENIORS AND
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES BY
FAILING TO PREPARE FOR EXTREME
HEAT. IT IS GETTING HOTTER, AND
WE ARE DOING ALL THAT WE CAN TO
REVERSE THAT TREND. BUT AS WE
KNOW, THAT TREND IS CONTINUING,
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
JURISDICTIONS PLAN FOR THIS AND
HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY NEED
WHEN THEY'RE HIT WITH THE
CRISIS. AND THAT'S NOT JUST
THEIR RESOURCES OR THE STATE'S
RESOURCES. IT'S FEDERAL FEMA
EMERGENCY RESOURCES. THIS BILL
TAKES US ONE STEP CLOSER TO
HAVING THAT REALITY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. TAKE THE VOTE. NOW WE
HAVE A MOTION. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATORS DURAZZO I. DURAZZO I
CIERTO. DALI GLASER. GLASER, I.
SKINNER WAHAB. WAHAB I WIENER.
WIENER I 40 ZERO. OKAY. WE'LL
LEAVE IT. VOTE OPEN, WE HAVE ONE
MORE. WE HAVE ONE MORE BILL. WHO
IS NOT HERE? OH, THERE HE IS.
WALKING THROUGH THE GRAND
ENTRANCE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. WE ARE READY FOR YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
OKAY. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR,
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
2593. THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL
AND A BIPARTISAN BILL THAT I'M
AUTHORING JOINTLY WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS HOOVER AND NGUYEN,
FOCUSING ON HAVING A BETTER
REGIONAL, COORDINATED APPROACH
TO TACKLING HOMELESSNESS IN OUR
COUNTY. IT'S A PROBLEM ON ALL
COUNTIES. I WILL NOTE THIS
MORNING THEY CAME OUT WITH OUR
POINT IN TIME COUNT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. SO THE GOOD NEWS IS
THERE ARE FEWER HOMELESS IN
SACRAMENTO, A DECREASE BY 29. IT
WAS OVER 8000. NOW IT'S 6500
ISH. BUT THE BAD NEWS IS ARE
STILL 6500 PEOPLE SLEEPING
OUTDOORS. AND AS WE KNOW, THEY
SAY OVER HALF OF THEM HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES. SO
WHAT THIS LEADS US TO REALLY
FOCUS ON AND WHAT OUR GRAND JURY
REPORTED LAST YEAR IS A LACK OF
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS, BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY, WE ARE ALL IN
THIS TOGETHER IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, AND WE'RE FOCUSING
THAT ON THE BUDGET ALLOCATIONS
TO CITIES. WE'RE SAYING WE WANT
COUNTIES TO HAVE REGIONAL PLANS
TO WORK ON THESE ISSUES
TOGETHER. SO THIS BILL WOULD DO
WOULD SET UP A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY, LIKE MANY OF YOU CAME
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS WELL.
WE HAVE JPAS ON WASTEWATER
TRANSPORTATION. THE LIBRARY
SYSTEM IN YOUR COUNTIES, OURS
HERE AS WELL, BUT NOT ONE ON THE
MOST PRESSING ISSUE FACING OUR
COMMUNITY. THIS WOULD SET UP A
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY AND A
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE WHERE THE
COUNTY AND THE CITIES WITHIN THE
COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO WOULD WORK
TOGETHER AND PARTNER TO FOCUS ON
A REGIONAL PLAN. THAT'S ONE OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE TAKING
HERE. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, JUST
BETTER COORDINATION AND POOLING
RESOURCES. SO THIS GPA WON'T
HAVE A LAND USE AUTHORITY TO
CITE THESE THESE LOCATIONS. IT
WON'T USE OTHER JURISDICTIONS
DOLLARS, BUT IT WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WORK TOGETHER IN
PARTNERSHIP TO TACKLE THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE FOR SACRAMENTO.
SO WITH ME TODAY IS APRIL
LUDWIG, WHO'S THE CEO OF HOPE
COOPERATIVE, A LOCAL HOMELESS
ORGANIZATION, MAKING A
DIFFERENCE HERE IN SACRAMENTO
AND ASK FOR HER TO TESTIFY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. OKAY. IT'S LUDWIG,
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. SO MY NAME IS
APRIL LUDWIG. I'M THE CEO OF
HOPE COOPERATIVE. IT'S MY HONOR
TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT AB 2593.
OUR ORGANIZATION HAS
CONTINUOUSLY PROVIDED SERVICES
HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION
FOR 43 YEARS. AND IN THOSE
SERVICES, WE PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES, THOSE WHO ARE
SUFFERING OR WHO HAVE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE CHALLENGES, AS WELL AS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AS WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS JOINT
POWERS OF AUTHORITY, WHAT WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BRING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TOGETHER TO SUPPORT IN
INCREDIBLY THINKING ABOUT A
PLAN, A STRATEGIC PLAN AS WELL.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE THE JPA WOULD BE SUPPORTING
HOMELESSNESS WITH, MAKING SURE
THAT OUR LEADERS SET GOALS,
SHARE RESOURCES, AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY, FOLLOW A REGIONAL
STRATEGIC PLAN TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS, SUCH A PLAN HAS
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED AND
DEVELOPED BY SACRAMENTO'S
CONTINUUM OF CARE PROVIDERS.
SACRAMENTO STEPS FORWARD BUT
NEEDS THE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT A
JPA OR JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
WOULD PROVIDE. SO WE'RE
INCREDIBLY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
PLAN, SPECIFICALLY BASED ON THE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE WITH
THE INDIVIDUALS, WE PROVIDE
THOSE SERVICES TO. THANK YOU SO
KINDLY FOR CONSIDERING THIS.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? OKAY. SEEING NONE,
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OKAY.
SEEING NONE. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM. YES, SENATOR
DARLING, YES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
JUST HAVE A QUESTION. I'M COME
OUT OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT, AND I
THINK WE HAD THE ABILITY TO DO
JPAS WITH OTHER AGENCIES WITHOUT
HAVING TO DO LEGISLATION. WHY IS
THIS? WHAT CAN THESE AGENCIES
NOT DO AND WHAT'S THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE BILL? YEAH,
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT. THERE ARE
SOME JPAS I KNOW YOU YOU HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AS WELL, THAT WERE CREATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE STATUTORILY. AND
SO, YOU KNOW, WE JUST THOUGHT
HAVING THE, HAVING THE STATE
CREATE THIS WOULD, WOULD PUT
MORE SUBSTANCE IN IT. AND WE
THINK TOO, IT'S A REALLY GOOD
TIE IN WITH WHAT WE'RE DOING IN
THE BUDGET. BECAUSE IN THE
BUDGET WE'RE SAYING MORE AND
MORE WE WANT JURISDICTION TO
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP. SO, THAT
WAS DEBATED, BUT WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE JURISDICTIONS. NONE OF
THEM OPPOSE THIS MEASURE, AND IT
IS ALL VOLUNTARY. ALL THESE
JURISDICTIONS WOULD HAVE THE
CHANCE TO OPT IN OR CONVERSELY,
OPT OUT AS WELL. SO JUST BACK TO
MY BASIC QUESTION, THOUGH. I'M
GONNA SUPPORT YOUR BILL. BUT BUT
I'M TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S THEY LEGALLY CAN DO A
JPA ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT HAVING
TO DO STATE LEGISLATION. ALL
THESE INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
COME TOGETHER, FORM A JPA, RIGHT
NOW THAT'S POSSIBLE. OKAY. BUT
SOME CONVERSELY, SOME JPAS ARE
CREATED THROUGH. OKAY. THAT'S
FINE. THANK YOU. OKAY AND JUST A
CLARIFICATION, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
COULD YOU CLARIFY THAT YOU ARE
ACCEPTING ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS? YES. I'M SORRY, I
THOUGHT I SAID THAT, BUT MAYBE I
WENT TOO FAST. ALL OF THEM.
THANK YOU. GREAT. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR GLAZER
MOVES THE BILL, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY CLOSING REMARKS. YEAH.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US.
THIS IS AN ISSUE IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, AND HOPEFULLY THIS
CAN BE A MODEL THAT CAN HELP
SACRAMENTO BUT CAN BE UTILIZED
ELSEWHERE IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. CALL FOR THE
VOTE. MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING. SENATORS DURAZO Ã
DURAZO I SATO. SATO I DOLLY,
DOLLY I GLASER. GLASER I
SKINNER. SKINNER I WAHAB. WAHAB
I WIENER. WIENER I 7 TO 0. OKAY,
WE CLOSE THE ROLL ON AB 2593.
THERE YOU GO, WE GO BACK TO THE
WORK. SO DO YOU WANT ME TO START
FROM THE BEGINNING? YEAH. YOU
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE. OR DO YOU
WANT. NUMBER NUMBER ONE. NO,
JUST GO WITH NUMBER ONE. SO
WE'LL GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB 817. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. CURRENT
VOTE IS 023 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SEN DOLLY. DOLLY.
DOLLY. NO SKINNER. WAHAB. WIENER
0 TO 4. IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION,
I'LL CLOSE THE ROLL FIRST. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLL
FIRST. 0 TO 4. THE BILL FAILS.
OKAY, 0 TO 4. THE BILL FAILS.
THERE'S NO OBJECTION. WE'LL
LEAVE GRANT RECONSIDERATION.
OKAY ITEM
NUMBER TWO. AB 11. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON ENERGY,
UTILITIES AND COMMUNICATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 1 WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS.
DOLLY. DOLLY NÓ. SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE 5 TO 2. CLOSE THE
ROLL. CLOSE THE ROLL. MOVE ON TO
ITEM FOUR. AB 2302. 0300. SORRY.
ITEM THREE AB 2085. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 1
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS DOLLY. DOLLY NØ SKINNER
. SKINNER. AYE. FIVE TO CLOSE
THE ROLL AND WE 5 TO 2. OKAY, WE
MOVE ON TO ITEM FOUR, AB 2302.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 0
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS SATO. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE. 7 TO 0.
CLOSE THE ROLL. ITEM FIVE AB
2350. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. CURRENT
VOTE IS 620, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER. AYE 7 TO 0. CLOSE THE
ROLL. ITEM SIX. OH, NO, WE DON'T
NEED THAT. OKAY. ITEM SEVEN, AB
20. WE DID THAT ALREADY. YES.
OKAY. ITEM EIGHT. YES 2680 AB
2684. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS
4 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. SENATORS CIERTO. CIERTO.
NO. DOLLY SKINNER. SKINNER AYE.
5 TO 1. OH. CLOSE THE ROLL.
OKAY. WE CLOSE THE ROLL. GO ON
TO ITEM NINE, AB 2715. MOTION IS
TO PASS THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO
0 WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS. DOLLY DOLLY. AYE.
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE. 7 TO 0.
THAT'S THE LAST ITEM. ALL RIGHT,
THAT'S IT. CLOSE TO ROLL. CLOSE
THE ROLL ON ITEM NINE. YEP.
THAT'S IT. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY, PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE, EVERYONE'S
PARTICIPATION COMMENTS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT TO US. WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOU IN THE OFFICIAL
RECORDS. THANK YOU, EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION.
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, JONATHAN AND,
SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU EVERYONE.